um
is
threesomes
i actually
yes
foreign
if you want to record people speaking
i know
good morning everyone
we will call this meeting of the house
judiciary committee to order
and we will begin by
doing the pledge of allegiance and
representative sylvia could you lead us
in that
allegiance to the flag of the united
states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you
mr clerk would you mind calling the role
this morning
representative alexander
is my microphone on
apparently not
joe is not here
he is in another committee this morning
representative andrus
representative kurds
representative chase
representative di lorenzo here
representative gordon here here
representative greene
here
representative horrigan
representative kelly
representative kenny
representative langley here
representative macbeth
representative mclean here
representative
here representative
here
representative page
representative simpson
here
representative
smith representative sylvia
representative trottier
representative walper is here
thank you mr clerk
our first item of business this morning
is a hearing on constitutional amendment
concurrent resolution 18
reproductive medic
relative to reproductive medical
decisions
just
for
our purposes this morning
i'd note that we do have a number of
people who wish to testify today
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to provide each of the sponsors of
the bill who wish to testify with five
minutes to
introduce their bill and to speak to the
bill
and then we're going to
have other people who wish to speak
be restricted to a three-minute period
for for their testimony
if you have handwritten testimony or
type testimony that you want to submit
you can certainly submit that
what we're really interested in doing is
hearing from you and your thoughts with
regard to the proposal
we had hearings yesterday
we had some difficulty with regard to
the microphones
in and understanding what people were
saying and that's particularly uh an
issue with people wearing masks
because uh the the voices tend to be
blunted and so if you wish to wear a
mask you're certainly entitled to do so
uh you could if you uh if you want to
you could take off the mask we have by
the speaker over here put
wipes sterile wipes in case you want to
wipe down the microphone if that be the
case
you're not not compelled to take off
your mask but if you did it might be
easier to be understood
we're going to go through the we'll call
the speakers first and the
representatives first and then we'll
call for the rest of the testimony this
morning
the prime sponsor of this bill is
representative
toll
and
will call upon the representative to
provide her testimony and introduce the
bill
and representative merner has agreed to
be our timer today
thank you representative merner
dear honorable members of the judiciary
committee
my name is amanda elizabeth hole and i
represent cheshire 16 the city of keene
at large i just got to ask you just take
microphone down closer to your mouth so
we can
hear you okay i'll start over dear
honorable members of the judiciary
committee my name is amanda elizabeth
toll and i represent cheshire 16 the
city of keene at large i'm here today as
the primary sponsor of cacr18 new
hampshire's reproductive liberty
amendment to add constitutional
protections for reproductive rights to
the new hampshire state constitution
the other sponsors of this bill and i
firmly believe
in reproductive justice meaning that all
people regardless of race class or
gender have the right to make autonomous
reproductive decisions and should have
the resources and support to do so
this bill was written broadly by
speaking to reproductive medical
decisions it covers everything from
abortion to poor sterilizations which
have targeted communities of color
throughout history
we cannot emphasize enough that
reproductive justice should include both
abortion justice and the right to have
children
my personal story relates deeply to why
i'm bringing this bill before you today
when i was a teenager i needed to access
abortion care i had to comply with the
parental notification law
even though my parents are pro-choice i
found it deeply unjust that my parents
would not need to be involved in the
decision to give birth yet would have to
be involved in my decision to terminate
a pregnancy
i thought long and hard about other
people in a similar situation to me who
came from different homes
where perhaps they would face sheer
hostility and would have people trying
to dissuade them from doing what was in
their best interests
my own abortion story was the beginning
of my journey of fighting for bodily
autonomy when i went to hampshire
college i began to get involved with
reproductive rights activism including
working with the civil liberties and
public policy program and organizing its
annual conference from abortion rights
to reproductive freedom transforming the
movement for reproductive justice
through this work i learned about more
stories that widen my view about what
reproductive justice is
specifically two that i'll mention today
one was the story of rosie jimenez in
post roe vs wade
jimenez died after she was denied access
to an abortion
unable to afford the cost out of pocket
she was also unable to use medicaid
funds for the legal procedure and was
forced to resort to a dangerous abortion
that took her life
rosie's story taught me how
intersectional abortion justice is this
is a racial class and gender justice
issue
the second was the abortion speak out
that is part of this annual conference i
heard a black feminist speaker loretta
ross share her story ross had an
abortion when she was a teenager and at
23 she experienced sterilization abuse
and she was rendered sterile with the
dalkin shield
what i learned through hearing these
stories was that i as a privileged white
woman who had faced some barriers had
centered my activism primarily on
abortion legality
however
my sisters
of color
and brothers too were not only fighting
for abortion justice but also for their
right to have children
this was a crossroads i realized that my
activism could just benefit myself and
people like me or i could learn from
bypoc feminists to also fight for the
right of all people to have children
children alongside abortion justice
this is why this bill is specifically
written to include all reproductive
medical decisions
not just abortion
the fundamental lesson from rosie's
story loretta's story my story and
millions of other pregnant people
throughout history is state interference
with a right to have or not to have
children is state sanctioned violence
this bill is unique in that it is a
constitutional amendment and
constitutional protections for
reproductive rights are the gold
standard
in addition to the purposely bold and
progressive content of the bill the fact
that it is a constitutional amendment
means it is not subject to the
governor's veto it is a lot harder to
undo and would mean that we would not
need to fight tooth and nail for
reproductive freedom each time there is
a change in control of the state
legislature
town and city councils would not be able
to pass local ordinances infringing on
the right to make personal reproductive
medical decisions vermont a state that
has consistently promoted progressive
protections for its constituents is
moving towards constitutional
protections of reproductive rights
new hampshire residents are
overwhelmingly pro-reproductive freedom
but their political party might not
align with them on this issue
putting this issue on the ballot as a
constitutional amendment will allow
residents to directly show support for
reproductive rights an issue of personal
liberty that is very important to
granite staters
this bill should be seen as
complementary legislation to other
reproductive rights bills this session
myself and my co-sponsors full-heartedly
support the other pieces of reproductive
rights legislation
being introduced today
i am asking the judiciary committee
to do justice by granite staters and
protect their reproductive liberty by
voting on to pass on cacr18
new hampshire's reproductive liberty
amendment
constitutional protections for
reproductive rights
are the gold standard
i also enthusiastically support hb 1674
the access to abortion care act and hb
1673 to repeal new hampshire's abortion
ban and ultrasound requirement which i
am a proud co-sponsor
in light of there being many voices in
the room to speak on these essential
reproductive rights measures i will be
submitting written testimony in favor of
the other bills being introduced today
thank you very much for hearing my
testimony
thank you are there questions
representative mclean did you have a
question yes thank you mr chair and
thank you for taking my question so
roe
solidifies a woman's right to an
abortion but it also enables states to
regulate abortion later in a pregnancy
so if this bill
were to pass
would it trump grow
and how would that impact new
hampshire's right to regulate
relative to the current state so for
example would new hampshire still have
the right for example to restrict
abortion in the ninth month of pregnancy
or would that be lost if this
constitutional amendment were to go
through
we have many other speakers who are
going to be speaking today and so
they will be addressing some of your
questions so i can
i can defer
the questions
to the other speakers and if they're not
answered i can get back to you i do want
to say this is important for me as a
reproductive justice activist
roe is meant to be the floor
not the ceiling so
i
believe in addition to legality
abortion access
is essential
and the right to have children
is
essential
and my goal
as a reproductive justice activist
is to build onro
not to stop it bro
thank you so much
thank you are there other questions
representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so this bill affects
personal
reproductive medical decisions
is it
a doctor's
personal
decision if the state
prohibits the doctor from
performing abortions
i want to be very clear representative
that
doctors and patients should be making
reproductive medical decisions
not the new hampshire state legislature
that's my position
yeah you can follow up
but this is a
personal right
of
the person who is
pregnant
and the state has
licensing capabilities over doctors
does this interfere with the state's
administration of doctors
licensing
i do not believe it does
thank you
i believe this i just want i believe
this piece of legislation empowers
doctors to do what's best for their
patients
i believe that the attacks that we've
seen in this legislative body
have harmed medical professionals to
provide the care that is best for their
patients and overwhelmingly in this
state medical professionals have come
out in opposition to all that tax on
reproductive freedom that this
legislature has passed
and they are supportive overwhelmingly
of the three proactive pieces of
legislation being proposed today to
protect reproductive rights
representative otter did you have a
question thank you mr chairman and thank
you for taking the question
representative are you aware that in the
state of new hampshire abortionists do
not have to be licensed
representative notter
i think that question
does not directly relate
to this this is protecting the state
from interfering with the right
of reproductive rights
this is a bill about liberty
and it is going to provide protections
for people to make the choice to
terminate a pregnancy if that's what
they want to do
and to have children if they want to do
it is a protective piece of legislation
for patients and providers
representative nader did you want to
follow up yes thank you mr chairman
you had mentioned in your comments that
the decision is between the doctor and
the patient but we don't know that the
abortionists in new hampshire are
doctors because they don't need to be
licensed which is why i asked ultimately
the dis
medical professionals
and their patient and their patients
the state
of new hampshire politicians
you should not be interfering with this
concept what i believe is a basic human
right
people cannot control their lives if
they cannot control their fertility
representative horrigan
thank you very much mr chair um
first of all i
i would be extremely surprised if uh
just anyone can perform an abortion in
new hampshire i'd never heard that claim
before and and um
would this allow this is the same phrase
that's used in the u.s constitution in
the second amendment and certainly there
are some regulations on guns in spite of
what some people think that doesn't say
that anybody can take a gun just
anywhere so
likewise if we pass this wouldn't we
still be able to have certain
regulations like it probably would be
reasonable to require abortions to be uh
performed by a licensed medical
professional which i believe is the law
now anyway
absolutely representative
yep so thank you
other questions
representative mclean you have another
question
yeah thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking my question i'm just
wondering are you aware of any other
states
that have incorporated
this kind of thing
into
their constitutions vermont is moving
towards it and i believe they will be it
is very likely they will be the first
state
and it is our job
as politicians to plant seeds for what
is good what is going to give our
constituents the most protections the
the most
freedom to value their civil liberties
to value gender justice
to value racial justice
and
even if something cannot pass right now
and i hope it does
if we don't plant seeds for it it will
never be possible
things never seem possible
until they are done
50 years ago did gay marriage seem
possible
absolutely not but myself
and my co-sponsors
we know that we're going to be on the
right side of history
and those of you who are trying to
infringe on people's human rights
the sanctity
of the right
whether or not
to have a child
something that impacts people's
physical
psychological and spiritual well-being
you will not be on the right side of
history
other questions
representative wolper
thank you mr speaker thank you for my
taking my question
the bill says she'll not uh
i don't i don't turn my microphone on or
off so
just speak up as loud as you can
representative wilper if you would we're
using the microphone to the extent it
communicates
so
the language here includes the word
inconvenience
which is
much stronger than any other language in
any constitution i've seen can you
explain what
what inconvenience means
in relation to not regulating
inconvenience
mandatory ultrasound requirements or
inconveniences in my opinion parental
notification laws or inconveniences
mandatory waiting periods or
inconveniences
all of these things
these reactionary
right wing
attacks that we've seen throughout the
country
to chip away
at reproductive rights
they're impeding access
and so i'm not interested in just
promoting legality
legality is essential row is essential i
want to uphold the sanctity of that but
i want to build on it
because it is not enough
rosy story speaks to that it wasn't
enough
we have
too many people what is a legal right if
you can't access that right
and so
i believe these access barriers
are also state-sanctioned violence
and i just i want to say we have a lot
of people speaking so i can continue to
take
some questions
but some of your questions may be
answered by our other speakers
do we have other questions
i i just have one question and that and
that is looking at the language that's
proposed for the constitution
and says the right to make personal
reproductive medical decisions is
inviolate and fundamental to the human
condition
it is
and the question is who will
and you explain what you intend that to
mean
but when this goes in the constitution
there's no definition of what that is
and so who will ultimately decide
what that means
so this cl so this is gonna
this opens the door this is going to
help pave the way
for reproductive rights in new hampshire
then
if the state chips away
it's going to be
challenged because you're going to have
it's going to the onus is going to be on
the state
to prove
that
they're not unduly inconveniencing
and so my hope
is that the state really
listens because constituents support
this
overwhelmingly in polls after polls
granite staters say that they support
reproductive rights
and so if you're gonna get in the way of
that
which you have
we're gonna keep challenging it
okay so if i could just follow up on my
question then
as i understand
your responses ultimately the court will
decide
what that means if it's going to be
based upon a challenge
the courts
will decide
ultimately but this opens the door
for new hampshire residents
to challenge
okay thank you those access barriers
any other questions from his toll
representative tolle excuse me
sing then thank you for your testimony
today
representative schultzer
thank you very much
good morning
i have passed my written testimony
up to the front
and i have my notes here so um
good morning
in november of 2018 81 of new
hampshire's voters
added
approved adding 22 more words
to our state's constitution
right to privacy
an individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion in private or
personal information
is natural
essential and inherent
those 22 words
were added as article 2 b
that amendment was about control
and who has it
new hampshire citizens want control over
their private and personal information
our proposal of cacr18
would be added as article 2 c
with 31 words which complement article
2b
and our language
the right to make personal reproductive
medical decisions
is inviolate and fundamental to the
human condition
neither the state nor any political
subdivision shall infringe
upon or unduly inconvenience this right
this amendment like 2b
is also about control and claiming it
unequivocally
this amendment didn't come out of thin
air
just like 2b didn't come out of thin air
it has inspiration from current statues
statutes and legislative intent let me
elaborate
in doing my research there is another
place in new hampshire law
where control over medical decisions are
in place
i'd like to share with you the first
part of chapter 137
j titled written directives for adults
without capacity to make
medical decisions in 137j
the purpose and policy statement
the state of new hampshire recognizes
that individual persons have the right
founded in the autonomy and sanctity of
a person to control the decisions
relating to the rendering of their own
health care
the new hampshire legislature amended
this chapter three times and
consistently reiterated
the purpose and policy statement
the state of new hampshire recognizes
that its citizens have the right
founded in the autonomy and sanctity of
a person to control the decisions
relating to the rendering of their own
medical care
and yet
when that new hampshire citizen
is pregnant
their rights to control decisions
related to their medical care and the
privacy of that personal information
is thrown away
pregnancy seems to be the line where
constitutional rights are stripped away
article one of the new hampshire
constitution
reads
all men are born equally free
and independent
therefore all government of right
originates from the people is founded in
consent and instituted for the general
good
there is no caveat in article 1 that
says
all men are born equally free and
independent except when pregnant
and yet
the loss of freedom and independence
is exactly what happens
in article 2
all men have certain natural
essential and inherent rights among
which are the enjoying and defending
life and liberty acquiring possessing
and protecting property
and in a word of seeking and obtaining
happiness
equality of rights under the law shall
not be denied
or abridged by this state on account of
race creed color sex or national origin
except when pregnant
a new hampshire citizen who is pregnant
loses the benefit
of their life
and liberty
to the mercy of the state
particularly if their pregnancy
is life-threatening or if their
pregnancy loses viability
their rights to seek happiness by making
reproductive medical decisions
independently
as is their natural right
are stripped away
they no longer have control over their
own body
they are enslaved to a law
marginalizing pregnant people by
stripping them of their natural
essential and inherent rights of control
over their reproductive medical
decisions
is not the new hampshire way
when a person does not have freedom over
their med reproductive decisions because
of state interference they are chattel
this is not the new hampshire way
new hampshire citizens value our natural
rights and it is unjust and undue and
undue burden to restrict the
reproductive medical decisions made by
new hampshire citizens it is time
it is time
to enshrine our values of freedom
of reproductive decisions into our state
constitution
because the constitutional protections
for reproductive rights
are the gold standard
i respectfully ask you to vote ought to
pass on cacr18
thank you
thank you are there questions for
representative aldschiller
representative mclean
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i'm just i'm just
sorry my microphone i'm just trying to
understand a little bit the the scope of
the phrase
unduly inconvenience are you aware of
anywhere in any other states where that
phraseology is used in relation to you
know reproductive law i'm just trying to
see if there has been a precedent or
anything established around that
phraseology anywhere
uh that phraseology
is a new hampshire original
because that's the new hampshire way and
we would like to
put
the questions because there seem to be
enormous questions um
within our state legislature
while the state electorate does not have
the same reservations and questions that
indeed
reproductive medical freedom
is a natural right
and it is not the state's
business
to make decisions about
whether someone should or shouldn't have
a child
whether they can or cannot access birth
control whether they should or shouldn't
or at what age
they might access a vasectomy whether
they should or shouldn't carry a
pregnancy to term regardless of whether
it's life-threatening whether
a pregnancy is
something that has to be carried in the
event of an incestual rape
all of that is a decision to be made
by the person for whom it affects
so i have no business making
reproductive decisions about your health
any more than you have business making
reproductive decisions about mine
thank you other questions
i think uh if i could ask a question
certainly
and it gets to the beginning of your
statement and talking about the
constitutional amendment with regard to
privacy which
was already voted on by the people and
one of the issues with that
particularly with regard to the
judiciary committee and our experience
on the judiciary committee is nobody
knows what it means
so
i think there's a general sentiment that
people want to have privacy
but
nobody knows how that applies to their
lives
and so
the question is was that constitutional
amendment actually meaningful
and i guess that's the question that i
would have with regard to this and that
it is so general
the question is
what does it mean and it gets to the
question i think i asked before is
are we just going to allow the court to
decide
what this means by virtue of cases is
that the intent
so the intent of
any constitutional amendment and i would
i would hazard to say the intent
when writing the new hampshire new
hampshire constitution
was to set in place a series of values
that with which we value so for instance
you re you referenced
my beginning statement and
i did talk about article 2b
and
article 2
that says all men have certain natural
essential and inherent rights among
which are the enjoying and defending
life and liberty acquiring and
possessing
protecting property and in a word of
seeking and obtaining happiness
so
that is not a prescriptive statement of
exactly how to enact that and it is then
as we know the responsibility of the
citizenry as outlined in part one that
we are to govern ourselves and that we
govern in
with consent um
and with a
with the government originating from us
founded in consent and instituted for
the general good so
the constitution is a value statement
and the legislature and the courts have
to uh
dig through the weeds
and figure out how that applies i would
hazard to say that also in the
constitution
women
are not mentioned
and yet we are subject to all of the
laws of this state
and so there is an interpretation that
we should be included so the
interpretation part is our job
thank you
any other questions
xingnan thank you for your testimony
today thank you very much for your time
and we have another co-sponsor rebecca
representative mc williams
thank you chair thank you colleagues
it's a pleasure to be here
my name is representative rebecca
mcwilliams i represent the west side of
concord
i'm here representing the women of
it's 2022
and we feel empowered and free and it is
the first time that i'm pleased to offer
this constitutional amendment for the
women of concord and new hampshire
i just want to tell you a personal story
a little bit about me and reproductive
health
i'm a mom of three
and it has taken great effort to become
a mom of three
i worked really hard and spent a lot of
money to have twins four years ago
and was successful
and immediately after i had those twins
i found myself pregnant again
i wasn't ready to have another child i
didn't know what to do
i prayed about it my husband and i
talked about it long into the night
and it turned out that that pregnancy
was not viable
i ended up having an ectopic pregnancy
that could have killed me
and my ability to make the decision to
have surgery and end that
saved my life
taking away a woman's decision
about what she does when she's pregnant
can indeed risk the life of the mother
and in my case it would have killed me
if i could not have had that removed
so i'm down one ovary
but i was fortunate enough with a little
bit help of science to get pregnant
again
and have a little girl who's now one
year old
and i'm very lucky
but that could have gone really badly
and a lot of horrible things could have
happened during that high risk pregnancy
because i have high blood pressure
and once again
between myself and my doctor we had to
look into what were the right decisions
every month every time i had a scan we
had to look into that and it was between
me and my doctor
and so i'm here representing the women
of concord and the women of new
hampshire to let you know that we will
make the decisions that we need to make
that are right for us and right for our
families and there is no reason for the
state to get involved
and so i thank you for your time and i
wish for you to consider that it is 2022
and that women know what we're doing
and that we will take care and do the
right things thank you i'm happy to take
questions
any questions for representative mick
williams
uh representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
you mentioned that this is a decision
between you and your doctor
and the amendment is a personal decision
is protecting the personal decision
the doctor is licensed by the state do
you propose that we should have doctors
that are not licensed
the reason i mentioned myself and my
doctor is because i was referring i was
relying
on a medical professional
who's been through this thousands of
times with other people
and who understands where we were in the
process and what things looked like i do
not pretend to be a doctor nor do i play
one on television and so i believe that
the right thing to do is refer
with de confer with a medical
professional to make these decisions but
make no mistake it was not my doctor's
decision it was my decision and it was
informed by what my doctor was telling
me throughout the process
thank you
any other questions for the
representative
xenon thank you for your testimony today
thank you
we do have another representative we i
think that completes all of the sponsors
and co-sponsors
so at this point in time we'll be
looking at testimony for three minutes
we do have another representative who
wishes to speak and that's
representative folsom
good morning thank you um chairman
gordon and committee for hearing my
testimony today my name is beth folsom
and i represent grafton county district
11.
i'm coming before you today not to
discuss the morality of the law
there is going to be a lot of people on
either side of the issue that will
discuss that
and
i'm going to leave it to them
what i'm coming before you today to do
is to talk about the language that's
involved in this law
it is incredibly broad
and it will lead to a
large number of unintended consequences
while working in the colorado state
legislature
this same exact not exact wording but
really close came before the legislature
we discussed this of course
all throughout the capital you can
imagine all the little conversations
that pop up
and we came up with so many unintended
consequences
that the sponsor chose to pull the bill
before it went to the floor for debate
and no vote
and so
i'm concerned
that if this were to pass
we're going to end up with those
unintended consequences here
some of the issues in the language that
are concerning
is age
it doesn't talk anything about an age is
this
just someone who is of the age of
majority or is this someone who happens
to be 12 years old
we there has to be some
one involved in that child's life
hopefully it's a parent who
loves them and cares for them who is
helping take them to the doctor
that will be involved in this
a 12 year old unless
they're incredible and i know when mine
were 12 they would not have made a good
decision
that is important to have that parental
notification and advice
the second is gender
this doesn't talk anything about gender
and yesterday in this committee you
heard a bill
about the father's reproductive rights
i don't think from the
from how i read the room i'm not quite
sure that that's going to go very far
um and so but
all of a sudden you're leaving room in
here for fathers
to now sue
a woman who has had an abortion
because his rights were violated
so that's nothing that needs to be
cleaned up
and then also it doesn't really clarify
the intent
of is this just
for ending an abort a life or pregnancy
or is this also
for being able to get pregnant 15
seconds okay i'll just finish this one
up
i have more but um
so then we run into other problems with
that as well that the state has to get
involved in
okay and so i
do not support this bill and i would ask
you to vote itl
any questions for representative folsom
here representative oregon
um yes and i
guess i asked this question of a
supporter of this bill some might be
fair to ask this question but opponent
of the bill the
the key the phrase shall not uh be
infringed echoes the second amendment
and i suppose there's a lot of
disagreement about how much regulation
the second amendment u.s constitution
applies but historically haven't
hasn't that always been interpreted to
mean that the government has at least
some leeway to regulate
firearms so wouldn't there be at least
some uh
leeway here to uh regulate abortions but
it just wouldn't
but it would prevent the state of new
hampshire from
uh totally banning them
this were to um
and with that word
um inconvenience and infringe and those
kinds of words
basically
uh the fetal protection act like
protection act could stand in place
because
it's a reasonable infringement
it's a reasonable alternative
so if they really want to make sure
that they have
the the right to make that decision up
to birth then that's what they should
work on
not creating an overall
uh broad category that
then all of a sudden we're back in here
making the same decision as to how we
are going to inter interpret that that
piece of legislation
representative chase
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i'm curious what your
thoughts are on
the last
speaker's testimony where she talked
about
equality except for when you're pregnant
new hampshire citizens who are pregnant
lose their benefits of liberty and
life and liberty particularly if their
pregnancy is a life-threatening or
pregnancy loses visibility how do you
feel about that do you feel that
the law the way it is now the
constitution
is equal for everyone
thank you for that question and i'm
going to try and there's a few parts to
that
so
[Music]
the first part oh gosh i'm trying to go
back to the first part of your question
um i'm going to start with the etopic
pregnancy
that is a risk to the health of the
mother
there is no
vans in this state even within the fetal
protection fetal life protection act
she is allowed to get an abortion if it
is
going to
as she was afraid would kill her etopic
pregnancies are very very dangerous
so that would not be stopped by the laws
that we have right now
again
i
the women in the state do have a right
to have an abortion up to the week 24
for any reason whatsoever
and any time
we basically just followed what the
supreme court said of at 24 weeks
where you're looking at there's another
life involved so we wanted to protect
the second life as well as the life of
the mother
other questions
yes representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i want to focus on the
unduly
inconvenience at this point
would it be
considered unduly
inconvenient to require a
medical professional to be the person
performing
the procedure that's desired here
um
in my own personal opinion i'm going to
give this and i think
being on the health human services
committee we deal with a lot of these
and plus the licensure board and all of
that
if you think about the people who
perform other
types of invasive uh procedures on a
woman's body or on a man's body
most of them
have to be licensed
and um so that i would definitely want
it to be a person for the safety of the
mother
um to you and the woman i would want
that person to be licensed and very
carefully
licensed process go through
other questions representative simpson
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question representative
um i was looking at the
bill after you mentioned age and you're
right i don't see age listed anywhere
there but i'm wondering if you can tell
me if it's if the
if anyone's age is talked about in other
places in the constitution in other
articles
i don't think so
i i'd have to
check with the constitution specialist
but i do not believe in reading um that
there is a law regarding age i'm maybe
someone on here could answer that better
but
maybe
we shouldn't be the first ones to
change that i mean
i want to say this correctly
by keeping with the language
of the constitution
by not mentioning age
in this
situation if this went through
then it would open the door
for
anyone of any age
could could receive any
type of reproductive
procedure
thank you
other questions
seeing none thank you representative
thank you
i have a card from senator whitley
senator whitley here
tony la branch
good morning house judiciary committee
for the record my name is representative
tony lebranch and i represent the town
of amherst i come before you today to
talk about the numbers not debate
anything in the bill
uh
i come before you as a representative of
purple district it seems that there's
one thing the majority of amherstonians
can agree on and that is reproductive
rights are a basic human right
polls show that the majority of granite
staters
66 in 2014 73 in 2018 and most recently
as representative alt schiller shared 83
of granite staters agreed that the issue
of reproductive rights is settled
this cacr
simply makes
it so that most granite
that the idea that most great states
agree on uh that it is a fundamental
human right and that it should be
protected constitutionally protected in
that manner
let the people of new hampshire have the
final say on this matter so that we can
finally put this hyper-partisan and
divisive issue to rest that's why i
asked the committee to recommend ought
to pass thank you
thank you representative are there
questions
see none thank you for your testimony
patrice meyers
thank you ladies and gentlemen of the
house
um i gotta speak up a little bit sorry
um
just want to make one point on one of
the other testimonies man
women are mentioned in the constitution
at the time it was written
man meant
people in general
mankind
that's how they use that term thank you
the issue here is it is a constitutional
amendment
another change
to a
document that has been changed beyond
recognition
up till now
an amendment cannot be made to the
constitution that
opposes that constitution and this one
does it flies in the face of right to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness we're talking about the
mothers who are pregnant
but we don't talk about
what's in her
we talk about having or not having
children as if their property
what about the child who doesn't have
any say about how it got there
a definition of life is growth and
development and if i can bring science
into it when a sperm from
excuse me when a sperm fertilizes an egg
that egg
starts to develop and grow
it starts to become a human
child not an elephant
as i saw on the sign outside
our writers of the constitution relied
upon god
i know i shouldn't mention him but
he doesn't depend upon your belief or
unbelief
he is
and the truth doesn't depend upon
opinions
or perceptions
it is
and the point of the fact is that
when you get rid of
the life that is in the womb it is
murder unless and we do again have laws
that stipulate if the life of the mother
is in danger of course not
in terms of rape and all that that's why
we have parents
so that they can guide their children
through this
but as a general rule
to snuff out that life that had no say
in how it got there
is murder
thou shalt not murder
my last point is
you all make an oath
to protect the rights of the
constitution that includes the rights of
everyone born and unborn
to pursue life
to continue in their development and
growth
liberty
a chance to
live free from being
murdered
in the pursuit of happiness
when you kill an embryo
they have none of that
i am i'm here speaking for the the
voices that have no voice right now
time please keep your votes thank you
thank you thank you
are there any questions
i always forget that part
sing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you for coming
liz canada
good morning honorable members of the
house judiciary committee my name is liz
canada and i'm the advocacy manager of
planned parenthood new hampshire action
fund and planned parenthood of northern
new england we're here to support
cacr18
on december 1st the u.s supreme court
heard oral arguments in a case from
mississippi
in which the state overtly asked the
court to overturn the roe v wade
decision
now on its heels
is the six-week abortion ban in texas
which has been in effect since september
1st 2021
and that ban is forcing those in texas
who are seeking abortion to take time
off work
find child care
perhaps travel thousands of miles
including here to new hampshire
or
instead to remain pregnant against their
will
we expect the supreme court to take up
the constitutionality of that case from
texas
though to be clear
they have not intervened and that near
total six-week ban remains in effect
today
as the u.s supreme court considers these
two cases that could overturn roe v wade
and allow states to ban abortion
altogether
this constitutional amendment would
enshrine the right to reproductive
medical decisions
every state legislature in our country
will need to make a decision if and when
the roe v wade decision is overturned
whether to further restrict access to
abortion
or instead to protect it and ensure that
abortion is safe legal and accessible
if this amendment is adopted the right
to make personal reproductive medical
decisions will be guaranteed by the new
hampshire constitution
we ask you to vote ought to pass on
cacr18
and because we already have a long day
ahead of us i will not be taking
questions on this legislation thank you
thank you
renee montiel
good morning everyone thank you for
allowing me this opportunity to speak
my name is renee montiel and i am a full
spectrum doula
that means that i support women during
pregnancy
childbirth postpartum
miscarriage
and abortion
i
my practice is um very trauma informed
and
i spent a lot of time with people in
their most vulnerable
positions
one of the things i often hear when
people tell their abortion stories
something very simple they wanted a
better life for themselves perhaps they
wanted to finish
school so they could go on
become successful and then have a family
the women that i deal with
these aren't these women
the women that i support and sit with
are women that are
not only in financial distress some of
them on the verge of homelessness some
escaping
domestic violence stories that you can't
even imagine women sitting next to me
with bruises on their neck from being
choked by their partners some of them
have had to stay in safe houses to try
to escape these situations
and these are the women that i'm
speaking for today because any bands
that we place in front of them any
obstacles we place in front of them
causes harm to them the children that
they already have
these are the stories that don't get
told often because nobody wants to
retell these stories no one wants to
relive this
these women have post-traumatic stress
and i support these women pro bono
because
i believe in this work that i do someone
asked me
how can you do this this is so
depressing because i don't believe in
just doing good i believe in doing
what's right
and that is incredibly important the
more barriers that these women have
the more violence is enacted upon them
violence enacted upon the children that
these women have and they're trying to
make a better life for themselves and
for their children
i do this as my work
i see this on a regular basis
and i'm here for them and i'm here to
support
the bill that amanda tol has
proposed because this will
make sure that these families and these
women will not have any more barriers to
having a decent life thank you thank you
are there any questions
see none thank you for coming today
jody newell is it
hello
thank you for allowing me to speak i'll
be short and sweet
my name is jody newell and i live in
keene i'm a proud mother of two and i'm
here today to speak in favor of cacr18
while my children's father passed away
shortly after they were born my boys
know that they were created in love and
that they are my top priority
since their father's passing however i
have had to make some tough decisions
one of which was to end pregnancy you
see i know very well
uh how hard it can be to lead a family
through grief loss and struggle
i can tell you that if i had had if i
had not had that choice i would not be
here today
sometimes i'm not sure how we got
through with just the three of us let
alone another
if there's one thing life has taught me
it's humility it's that i can't judge
another based on my own experience and
that even if i think i know what someone
is going through i can't possibly have
all the context so while i want to
impress upon you the weight of my
decision the circumstances surrounding
it etc at the end of the day the
decision was mine to make
i am the person most qualified to make
it and that is exactly why i stand here
today to support this resolution
because reproductive health decisions
are each individuals to make not the
states
this is a fundamental human right
and as such it should be codified in our
constitution thank you
thank you are there any questions from
ms noah
sing none thank you thank you for coming
today
and josie pinto
good morning committee my name is josie
pinto executive director of the
reproductive freedom fund of new
hampshire and a dover constituent i come
before you to express my support for crc
cacr18
the time is now to protect the essential
right to abortion that has been provided
by roe v wade for the last 49 years
to be honest it's the bare minimum as
amanda said roll row is the floor not
the ceiling
all the time i hear granite staters
claim to have the values of bodily
autonomy medical privacy and lack of
government infringement on health care
except when it comes to abortion
i am begging you all to extend those
values to abortion as well recognizing
what a deeply personal decision it is
for each individual that makes that
decision for themselves for their
families for their health and for their
well-being
on december 1st i was in dc for the
dobbs vs jackson hearing standing in
solidarity with my fellow abortion fund
leaders in the south who will be the
most impacted by the increased abortion
restrictions sweeping the country
the fact is many states in the south
have already are living in a post road
reality that's only going to get worse
i won't stand by and watch new hampshire
go down that same path
i won't stand by and watch a 24-week ban
turn into a 15-week ban as our rights
get chipped away over time
this needs to end here and now and this
bill is the strongest way we can
solidify that right
since this issue is so deeply personal
we should let voters show us where they
stand i'm asking you all to give them
the opportunity to do that
as we prepare for the reality of a
post-row america the reproductive
freedom fund of new hampshire is
preparing for increased barriers that
will likely cause many people to have to
seek care out of state and will likely
increase the amount of people traveling
to new hampshire for abortion care
our surrounding states vermont and
massachusetts are working hard to
enshrine those rights into law and scale
up their services in ways that can
accommodate this expected new influx i'm
heartbroken watching new hampshire do
the opposite strip funding from our
health centers pass increased
restrictions and eliminate entire
methods of abortion access through
enacting an ultrasound mandate
this is simply not in line with our
state values
for this and so many other reasons i
urge you to vote ought to pass on cacr18
thank you
thank you are there questions for ms
pinto
thank you seeing them thank you for your
testimony today
is there anyone else who has not
testified who would like to testify on
the
cacr18
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on constitutional amendment concurrent
resolution 18
and we will move on to our next item of
business
and that is a hearing on house bill
1674.
the primary sponsor of this bill is
our representative simpson
and we'll call upon her to provide her
testimony
and to introduce the bill
thank you
good morning
chairman gordon and fellow members of
the judiciary committee
for the record my name is alexis simpson
i represent rockingham district 36 the
towns of exeter new fields newmarket and
stratum
for 49 years abortion care has been safe
and legal in this country
and although it has never been easily
accessible to all women regardless of
race geographical location or income
over the past decade
it has become even harder to access as
many states across the country have been
intentionally restricting access
it is quite likely that in june the
supreme court will overroll roe v versus
wade
the expected overturning of roe poses a
threat to the constitutional right to an
abortion
the majority of my constituents and the
majority of granite staters expect that
women will still have the right to
access safe legal abortion when roe
falls
i'm introducing this bill
the access to abortion care act because
i feel we have a responsibility as
legislators to ensure that women have
access to safe legal abortion
i want to be clear that this bill does
not change any current new hampshire
abortion laws
it does however provide critical
protections to ensure that granite state
women and girls and their families can
work with their doctors to get the
health care they need in the majority of
situations
last year nearly 600 abortion
restrictions were introduced nationwide
90 of these restrictions have been
enacted into law including new
hampshire's first abortion ban in modern
history
this is more than any year since roe v
wade was decided in 1973.
for generations rowe has had bipartisan
support especially in new hampshire poll
after poll has shown that access to safe
legal abortion is popular and support is
at the highest it's been in two decades
with seven in ten americans opposed to
overturning roe v wade
unfortunately the current makeup of the
supreme court does not represent the
majority of people in new hampshire
this is why we need to be proactive
about putting women's rights into the
statute
according to the world health
organization restrictive abortion
regulation can cause distress and stigma
and risk constituting a violation of
human rights of women and girls
including the right to privacy and the
right to non-discrimination and equality
while also imposing financial burdens on
women and girls
this bill provides the opportunity to
protect the rights of women and girls to
privacy to non-discrimination and to
equality
the who also tells us that evidence
shows that restricting access to
abortions does not reduce the number of
abortions however it does affect whether
the abortions that women and girls
attain are safe and dignified
in 2020 the university of california san
francisco shared research from a
longitudinal study of women who have
been turned away from having an abortion
this study has taught us that denying a
woman an abortion creates economic
hardship and insecurity that lasts for
years
women who were turned away and went on
to give birth experienced an increase in
household poverty lasting at least four
years relative to those who received an
abortion
years after an abortion denial women
were more likely to not have enough
money to cover basic living expenses
like food housing and transportation
being denied an abortion lowered a
woman's credit score increased a woman's
amount of debt and increased the number
of their negative public financial
records such as bankruptcies and
evictions this brings me to my concern
for the medical system that supports
women and girls in new hampshire
this bill addresses access for all women
to equal to quality reproductive health
care
right now ob gyns who've been trained to
treat each individual patient as they
present to them
have to weigh whether they will come to
practice in a state that does not trust
doctors to provide appropriate care to
their patients
ob gyns need to be able to respond to
the needs of each patient they see
and not to feel as if they are under
constant threat
putting women's right to an abortion
into statute ensures that health care
providers for women will want to come
here to practice
women here need and expect quality
health care
it's a disservice to all women and
families if we're not able to continue
to attract the most professional and
dedicated doctors
as we anticipate the overturning of roe
v wade each state has the option to
choose to restrict or to continue to
ensure access to safe legal abortion
this is our opportunity in new hampshire
to build on our long-standing bipartisan
support for reproductive rights and put
this right into law
again this bill does not change the
current law including the 24-week
abortion ban what it does is ensure that
our constituents have access to abortion
care within the laws that currently
exist
finally the majority of our constituents
want roe v wade to stay intact
this bill is the new hampshire solution
to this
it's very clear in statute what the
restrictions are
it is not clear what rights women have
when it comes to access to care
this is our chance to say explicitly
that we believe women have a right to an
abortion within the limits of the
existing statute
thank you
and i'll take your questions
questions for representative simpson
representative chase
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question it's more of a thought for
you
do you have any idea in the states that
are now really banning abortions what
happens to those the children that
have a
wife that or a
woman who goes through a full pregnancy
but didn't really want to do that
because of a lot of the issues that you
just spoke of
do you know
how far
the government actually
follows or pro-life follows these
children do they put them in adoption
areas
what happens to these kids
um i don't have statistics about that
but i can say that
most of the legislation that i've looked
at in other states does not talk about
what happens to the child after the
child is born
i can say personally that i support
legislative
options for child care and to help with
with children after they're born for
families who are struggling but i don't
see that in other legislation no
other questions represented mclean
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so
what this legislation will do basically
it will trump roe and so what it does is
it falls back on our rsas so abortions
are legal except as restricted by these
existing rsas which i don't have a huge
amount of familiarity with but you did
mention in your testimony that the
24-week ban
would
still be allowable if this was to pass
so i'm just trying to understand
where these rsas put us relative to role
in terms of
do they basically maintain the status
quo of where roe is do they make it more
difficult less difficult relative to the
current state just trying to get a feel
for that
sure so currently
um
row is still in
is still a constitutionally protected
rate so
but what this does is it doesn't refer
specifically to rows so that if row
falls we've stated clearly in the
statutes the protections that we would
like as a state for women and girls in
new hampshire
and so that's why it refers to the
statute that we already have on the book
so right right now we do have access to
abortion up until 24 weeks in new
hampshire and this would just put the
rights that women have right next to the
restrictions in the statute
thank you
other questions
thank you for your testimony
if you haven't filled out a pink card
you need to do that too
i will thank you thank you
representative whitley uh senator
whitley excuse me
co-sponsor of the bill
good morning mr chair and members of the
the committee for the record my name is
becky whitley and i'm honored to
represent senate district 15
including the wonderful communities of
concord henniker hopkinton and warner
i'm grateful to testify in support of
this bill and thank the prime sponsor
for bringing forth such an important
piece of legislation
in the coming year as the u.s supreme
court sends the right to an abortion
back to individual state legislatures
each individual state will need to make
a decision
to continue to chip away at reproductive
rights and pass abortion bans or to
protect abortion access
and this bill asks what will our
decision be
the power that we hold to build new
hampshire policy
that shapes future generations that
supports a modern workforce to compete
in a modern economy
i personally think we don't need to wait
and see to
what the supreme courts decide to do we
do not need to wait for nine justices
before we as new hampshire legislators
stand up for granite staters
we have the opportunity in this bill
that proactively protects abortion
access in new hampshire and still
preserves what the majority passed last
year
so many of you might think that abortion
won't ever be banned in new hampshire
but i would ask you to look around the
country
it's already happening
states aren't waiting for the supreme
court's decision before passing abortion
restrictions
right now in state houses across the
country there are bills being considered
for six
eight
15-week bans
in florida
arizona
west virginia
missouri
arkansas south dakota
and indiana are all debating these bills
right now
and i want to speak to this issue
in a more personal way
as a woman still in my reproductive
years as a mother and as a granite
stater
i am truly terrified about what the
future of abortion access
looks like across the country
as well as here in our home state
i'm terrified
politicians will be able to decide the
course of my future
and the future of an entire generation
i'm terrified
politicians will be able to force me
and my contemporaries to carry
pregnancies
against our will
this is ultimate
governmental overreach and to me it
feels dystopian
i want to
make it clear that we are not in this
bill trying to legislate on a
hypothetical
and this is not hyperbole
without question we are at a crisis
moment in our country because roe v wade
will very likely be overturned by the
u.s supreme court in
june as someone born after roe was
decided
i could never have imagined we'd be in
this place
but we are
it's hard to imagine that a generation
behind me some of your daughters and
granddaughters
will not have the same rights that i
have
rights that my mother
your mothers your grandmothers my
grandmothers fought so hard for
these are rights that allowed me to go
to college go to law school
marry my equal
build a career i'm deeply proud of
run for office
and have a child who i adore above all
else when i was ready to be his mother
to be perfectly clear
abortion bans are stepping stones
24 weeks becomes 20
becomes 15
becomes six
becomes a ban on abortion entirely
even in this session our colleagues your
colleagues in the house are considering
an extreme six-week abortion ban
that is the goal
that is the playbook and the playbook
has unfortunately been successful in
eroding reproductive rights around the
country and here in new hampshire
again as a native granite stater i could
never have imagined that new hampshire
a state whose identity is so deeply
rooted in individual freedom would have
an abortion ban but here we are
but we have the opportunity to stop that
playbook and take a different path that
is uniquely suited for our beloved state
now is the time to do the right thing
now is the time to enact state level
protections to ensure that abortion
remains safe
legal and accessible no matter what
happens to
roe i think it's also important to point
out that we need a bill like this
to protect our fragile maternal health
system
here in new hampshire
i'm on the senate judiciary committee
and we have heard significant testimony
from our medical
community
that enshrining the right to have an
abortion into state law is an important
factor for future providers
we know how uncertain the future is for
reproductive health and rights in new
hampshire if a person wants to be an ob
gyn
they are now looking around at states
where their profession is respected
and their decisions are trusted
but as states ban abortion and
criminalize their profession why would
the best and brightest want to be in
these hostile states
and i want to call attention to what our
own dhhs
commissioner shivanet said at a recent
october 27
executive council needed
when she was asked about our fragile
maternal health
system she replied
i quote i think that it makes sense that
specialty and sub-specialty providers
would typically settle in states that
are more supportive and less restrictive
around family planning and abortion
the more restrictive we become the less
attractive new hampshire becomes for
those specialties end quote
to me that is unacceptable
to compete in a modern world to attract
young people in new hampshire which we
so desperately need to do we have to do
something about that
every granite stater should have access
to the health care that they need
including abortion without governmental
interference
so i would ask you
if you believe
that every individual should have the
right to make a personal private health
care decision
you should support this bill
if you support
nearly 50 years of supreme court
jurisprudence on abortion access
you should support this bill
and if you truly care about privacy
thank you for hearing my testimony i'm
happy to take any questions
questions for the senator
seeing none thank you very much thank
you another sponsor is representative
haken phillips
good morning
representative mary heck and phelps of
grafton county district 12 i represent
the good folks of hanover and lyme
and i rise in support of hb 1674
and a proud co-sponsor of this
legislation
let's get to what this bill does not do
to answer the representative's earlier
question
first the bill does not reverse rsa 329
colon 44
the law that went into effect on january
1st 2022
which is known as the 24 week abortion
plan
second the bill does not reverse rsa 132
colon 32 in the following sections
that's the law that went into effect
january 1st 20 2012
which is known as the parental
notification requirement for minor
children seeking abortions
so what does this bill do
as more eloquently summarized
this morning
the bill codifies the right to access
abortion care
it enshrines into law the requirement
that an individual may exercise their
private decision to terminate a
pregnancy without government appearance
except as provided in those two
provisions we just reviewed
the effect of this bill being enacted
into law enforces the 14th amendment's
guarantee that no one may be denied
liberty without due process of law it's
described currently in roe versus way to
planned parenthood versus casey
it states that the government will
protect the right to self-realization
autonomy and the pursuit of life liberty
and happiness
if hb 1674 is enacted it will show
granite staters that liberty is truly a
priority for all in new hampshire
it will permit pregnant people
the freedom to decide for themselves
when and if creating a family is the
right decision for them
it will permit individuals the freedom
to delay or bypass the creation of a
family in order to pursue college or
post-secondary education
and train
it will attract the best and the
brightest professionals to our state
it will protect the excellent health
care providers like those of my
community
currently employed by dhmz
in performing their jobs in
administrating medicine
it will permit child varying people to
more fully engage in our economy to
decide whether full part or no
employment is right for them
it will permit entrepreneurs the freedom
to start their own business
it will permit women and pregnant people
the ability to determine for themselves
the best and most productive use of
their time and energy
as a member of house ways and means i
have heard joint economic briefings in
which experts for from our state and
other and throughout the region
have identified a stalled economy within
our state
because many people that dropped out of
the workforce due to the pandemic have
not returned
state track demographics show that a
significant portion of the missing
workforce is in fact women
and i believe
oh it is believed that women are not
re-entering the workforce because
they're staying home to care for
children or family given child care
shortages
this law could be one of the tools new
hampshire puts into its toolbox to help
our economy reach full employment levels
and to help solve one piece of that
workforce shortage that plagues our
state
and remember
this bill reflects the majority of
public opinion that abortion care should
be accessible to all americans as
evidenced by pulling data
this bill will affect
will reflect the will of the granite
state
so why is this law needed now
it comes as no surprise to this
committee that the right to abortion
care is at issue before the united
states supreme court at this moment
as an american born after 1973
and that road decision
i am confronted with a stark reality
that my pursuit of life liberty and
happiness may soon be thwarted
that my right to seek full reproductive
health care which has been upheld in law
for 49 years may suddenly be restricted
the decision in dobbs v jackson is
expected as you've heard sometime this
spring possibly
this june by the united states supreme
court
so there is urgency among those who pay
attention
to codify the right to abortion access
in the state at the state level
at a time when many states are
preemptively restricting access the
sponsors of this bill are asking you the
members of the committee
not to expand an existing right
but rather to agree to secure the
current state of law and statute to make
sure that the individual's access to
abortion care in new hampshire does not
change
the time to act is now
so before this summer scotus decision is
issued your committee has the
opportunity to ensure that new hampshire
is one of the states that protect access
to abortion care
if new hampshire waits until after that
decision comes down
it may mean that pregnant people here in
the state are denied the right to seek
an abortion either temporarily or
permanently within the state
this obviously has a potential for
irreparable harm to granite staters to
your neighbors to your family members
and to your community
so i urge the community to adopt this
bill's otp i welcome any questions you
may have
thank you are there questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
i think that is all of the sponsors so
we now call upon those who have signed
up
to speak and limit them to three minutes
yes and the first person that we will
call upon
is senator perkins quoca
thank you chair and i believe i am one
of the co-founders
just to clarify
thank you so much nice to see all of you
today
uh i rise today in support of hb 1674.
this bill the access to abortion care
act is a thoughtful necessary and
popular bill
for those of you who are less familiar
with the bill the general idea is that
it codifies into loft roe v wade the
landmark case that made abortion legal
in all 50 states about a half a century
ago
before i was born
if passed into law abortion would remain
safe legal and accessible in most cases
in new hampshire regardless of what
happens at the u.s supreme court and
just to clarify
right now roe versus wade is is the
supreme court case that is protecting
women's right to an abortion up to
viability
and if the supreme court were to
overturn that then state statute would
become important which is why we are
bringing this bill
it's important to note that while i
remain deeply opposed to the 24-week ban
and mandatory ultrasound requirement
passed last year the legislation before
you does not seek to amend or repeal
that ban in any way or any existing new
hampshire abortion restrictions this
legislation specifically honors existing
state law and does not seek to override
it what it does seek to do is enshrine
in our state statutes a right to a safe
and legal abortion up to 24 weeks of
pregnancy
i have heard from many of my colleagues
on both sides of the aisle that they
support roe vs wade
well here is your chance to show that
support
passage of this bill would mean we
joined 15 other states and the district
of columbia in protecting abortion
rights all of our neighboring states
affirmatively recognize and protect the
right to an abortion in their state law
maine vermont massachusetts connecticut
rhode island and new york
for years i have heard we don't need
this in new hampshire
we are a unique state that values
privacy and has bipartisan support for
abortion rights
for many years that was indeed the case
but friends i think we can all recognize
that times have changed we do need this
now
we are on the verge of this country
overturning 50 years of a constitutional
right to a safe and legal abortion
i look around this room and i see other
women in office
other women that are accomplishing
things in their own right
i know that the makeup of this room
is only because women have been able to
take hold of their futures by
controlling their own body and their own
destiny and that means being able to
decide when if and how they have
children
the position i am in
and others are in as state senators and
state representatives is awe-inspiring
i'm grateful for the freedom and
reproductive health and other choices
that got me here
but come june
when roe versus wade could be gone we in
new hampshire will know 15 seconds
be able to ignore
the reality
of the altered landscape of care
providers in new hampshire are preparing
for a world where many patients and
those who can afford it will leave the
state to receive service
our providers have told us they've
already seen patients from texas at
their health care centers senator if you
could just finish up that would
chair i didn't realize there was a time
restriction i was just going to finish
my statement well we're still going to
hold you to the three minutes even if
you didn't realize it so
i know that this is a personal issue
i know that some of you are
uncomfortable even hearing about this
bill or talking about abortion
emotions can run high and beliefs are
strong and that's okay
senator
can you finish
sure the other senator was allowed to
make their full statement so i'm going
to make mine as well excuse me
can you just finish up sure i will
finish up
i am a co-sponsor so i'm going to finish
my statement our job is to put aside our
personal beliefs and do what is best for
our constituents and for the future of
our state
we must trust women and health care
providers we must remember our granite
state values of personal privacy and
individual liberty and we must recognize
that the vast majority of our country
and our state support abortion rights
it's actually not a divisive issue at
all
senator
we're done okay thank thank you we
told everybody at the beginning we have
three minutes today and i have to be
fair with everybody okay
thank you for your support on this bill
i look forward to speaking to any of you
at your convenience at more length thank
you senator
catherine
is it paternal
thank you very much i am here to testify
in opposition to house bill 1674.
my name is catherine petternell i'm from
wolfeboro i have a bachelor of science
in nursing
i would simply like to suggest that
there are options to unwanted
pregnancies besides abortion or raising
the child
in 1989
when i was single and in college i
brought a daughter to full term
she was adopted by a loving family i
have never once suffered educationally
physically or financially as a result of
that decision thank you
any questions
thank you very much
liz canada
good morning again my name is liz canada
and i'm the advocacy manager planned
parenthood of northern new england and
planned parenthood new hampshire action
fund and we are here in strong support
of house bill 1674 the access to
abortion care act
so you've already heard today but i'll
reiterate
by june of this year four months from
now the u.s supreme court could overturn
the landmark roe v wade decision which
would result in 26 states immediately
acting or moving to ban abortion
outright
this isn't hyperbole this isn't a scare
tactic we're talking about 36 million
women which is half of the women in the
united states of reproductive age
losing access to abortion care in their
home state within this year
and we're already seeing what that looks
like in texas
new hampshire health centers have
already seen patients from texas
as more states ban to move to ban
abortion
patients if they have the money if they
have child care if they have the time
off of work
they're going to need to travel to
another state to access the care that
they need and we know that this will not
be an option for everyone
so for many of them they're going to be
forced to remain pregnant against their
will
and to carry that pregnancy against
their will
to be clear there is no one type of
abortion story that i could tell you one
in four women in the u.s will have an
abortion by the time she is 45 years old
and who that person is completely varies
already have a child
identify as catholic
there is no one abortion story or one
abortion patient
now here in new hampshire for decades we
have enjoyed bipartisan support of
reproductive rights including abortion
access
that support has been shown through
polling of voters but also through our
elected officials
in 1997 governor shaheen signed the bill
that repeals the pre-row abortion
restrictions
and she did that with republican
majorities in both the house and the
senate
who sent her that bill to sign
this bill the access to abortion care
act in front of you today had bipartisan
support in the senate last week
abortion access isn't a blue issue or a
red issue abortion is an essential and
safe health care service one that should
be accessible to people seeking it
as you heard this bill does not change
anything about the 24 week abortion ban
it doesn't touch or amend restrictions
instead this bill enshrines a person's
ability to access abortion into state
law prohibiting the government from
interfering with a patient's access to
abortion
new hampshire needs to provide critical
protections to ensure that granite state
women and families can work with their
doctors to get the health care they need
in the majority of situations this is an
opportunity to enshrine the test 15
seconds of the roe v wade decision into
state law which is something the
majority of granite staters want to see
we urge you to vote ought to pass on
house bill 1674. thank you i also have a
coalition letter from
medical organizations nonprofits
that i will share with you any questions
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today
frank knack
uh good morning mr chairman members of
the community thank you so much for the
opportunity to testify
uh most of the reasons that we support
uh strongly supported hb 1674 have
already been noted so i'll just give uh
somewhat of a personal story so i've
worked on similarities issues i'm from
up north but have worked in the south
for most of the last decade
including on abortion access in the deep
south
and you know
i think one thing that why it's so
important that new hampshire use this
opportunity to draw a line in the sand
to say that going forward we will ensure
the basic right to reproductive health
care in new hampshire
is that as senator whitley alluded you
know in the south where we're seeing six
week bans trigger laws et cetera they
didn't start out with those they started
out with trap provisions they started
out with 20 week plus bands they started
out with parental notification laws they
started out with funding restrictions
and now look we're at just a few years
later so i think it's important that
this committee take the opportunity to
enshrine this in state law and um or to
move the process forward to inchiness
and state law and thank you for the
opportunity to testify
thank you were there any questions for
mr nack
thank you for your testimony today
devin quinn
thank you chairman members of the
committee i'm devin quinn i'm the policy
director for the new hampshire women's
foundation
we support hb 1674 because we believe
that women and all people who can become
pregnant should have access to the full
range of reproductive services including
abortion we believe that it is crucial
that new hampshire take this step now
because women cannot wait to find out
what happens at the federal level we
must make a commitment to new hampshire
women to save legal and accessible
abortion care in our state
we believe that women have the right to
make decisions about their bodies their
families and their lives but not only is
this a choice
to end pregnancy or right but it is for
some a means to economic prosperity
safety and the ability to flee violence
the opportunity to pursue dreams and
develop thriving communities or the
chance even to protect her own health
in new hampshire women are more likely
to live in poverty than men are with a
gendered wage gap that increases by race
ethnicity and geography and they're more
likely to have been impacted by
interpersonal violence and bisexual
violence these social determinants of
health are all significantly impacted by
the ability to make reproductive
decisions for oneself including abortion
the right to seek an abortion
essential to women's autonomy health
wellness economic security and the
ability to be an active member of
thriving families and communities in our
state
we also hope you'll consider the
economic impact on women
women who seek but are denied an
abortion take four years on average to
return full time to the workforce after
the birth of a child
whereas women with access to
reproductive care are more likely to
invest in their schooling job training
and have higher rates of economic
security and women who have the
resources to control their fertility
have lower rates of poverty and their
families disrupting cycles of poverty
between multiple generations when women
are healthy and prosperous their
families succeed and our communities
grow stronger thank you and i have
additional written tests
yeah are there any questions
seeing none thank you for coming to
testify today
jake berry
good morning mr chair honorable members
of the committee my name is jake berry
i'm the vice president of policy at new
futures as many of you know new futures
is nonpartisan nonprofit health policy
and advocacy organization as new
hampshire's authorized kids count
organization we advocate for data-driven
policies to support granite state
families uh simply put access to
abortion is critical to the physical
behavioral and social and social
geoeconomic health of our state
data is clear that women who are denied
abortion report more life-threatening
complications including eclampsia and
postpartum hemorrhage as well as serious
medical conditions like migraines and
gestational hypertension
they're more likely to not have enough
money to cover basic living expenses
like housing food and transportation
and their children born as a result of a
denied abortion are more likely to live
below the federal poverty level
these impact these impacts have been
shown to disproportionately affect
populations who already have the
greatest obstacles to access to care
including
including those
with low incomes those living in rural
areas those with disabilities women and
people of color
for these individuals and families and
for all of us access to abortion is an
important part of our health care system
and a needed investment in our future
we urge you to support these bills
this bill as well as the
hb 1674 which is three that you'll hear
this afternoon to vote them on to pass
and to support granite state women and
families thank you i'm happy to take
questions
any questions for mr barry
sing none thank you again for your
testimony today
and josie pinto
hello again i'm here to express my
strong support for hb 1674 relative to
access to abortion care
this legislation is coming to you all at
a critical time we just experienced what
was likely the final anniversary of roe
v wade before it potentially gets
overturned and there's never been a more
important time for us to protect the
right to abortion here in new hampshire
which we know nearly 70 percent of
granite staters
support to think that we're about to go
back on nearly 50 years of precedent is
shameful
abortion is an incredibly safe medical
procedure
abortion pills are safer than tylenol
without needing to repeat what i said in
my last testimony i just want to make
one thing crystal clear
when roe v wade falls panic will ensue
across the country
this legislation is the most direct
chance we have at providing clarity and
preventing that panic and uncertainty
among granite staters when that moment
comes which is likely to happen in june
so it's up to you all
will you allow for panic and uncertainty
or will you vote in favor with the vast
majority of granite staters saying that
they want the right to abortion to be
protected here in new hampshire
regardless of what happens at the
federal level
i urge you all to vote ought to pass on
this bill thank you
any questions
are there questions from ms pinto
sing none thank you for your testimony
that is all the cards that i have is
there anyone else who hasn't testified
who would like to testify
yes
okay
thank you chairman and thank you to the
committee for hearing my testimony and
for all of your hard work i'm just going
to ask you i
was just told that people are having a
hard time hearing on the streaming
because one i think because of the
muffling of the mass for one thing but
but you need to speak loudly into the
microphone because people are having
difficulty here is this better that's
much better all right
thank you chairman and thank you to the
committee for hearing my testimony and
for all of your hard work
my name is mina webb and i'm from the
white mountains of new hampshire
i would like to start with a quote from
the late
ruth bader ginsburg
the decision whether or not to bear a
child
is central to a woman's life
to her well-being
and dignity
it is a decision she must make for
herself
when the government controls that
decision for her
she is being treated as less than a full
adult human
responsible for her own choices
thank you ruth
i think this is one of the most
responsible choices a woman could make
this is part two following up my
testimony yesterday
that was all about the lack of a stable
foundation to raise children in this
country
no universal health care affordable
child care or higher education
we are lacking the resources
i've included several quotes
from an article written by margot sanger
katz that appears on the new york times
increasingly women say they are delaying
having children until they can finish
school
establish a career and support
themselves
about half of women who have had an
abortion in 2014 were below the poverty
line
with another quarter very close to
poverty
it's people who don't have access to
health care access to contraception
who when facing an unattended pregnancy
don't have the resources to have another
child
nearly half of those who have abortions
are single
a third are living with a partner
and 14 percent are married
there are reasons why people choose
abortion
and there is reason why women reserve
this right
it is part of our constitution
if we revoke this right
it will not stop abortions from
happening
it will only stop safe abortions from
you heard this from real doctors
yesterday
please support the power of choice
who else can fairly decide when a woman
is ready to be a mother other than
herself
thank you for your time
thank you are there questions
seeing then i'm just going to ask you to
fill out one of those pink cards and
turn it in before you leave thank you
thank you
and did we have someone else who wishes
to testify
thank you mr chairman for the record i
did fill a pink card out i'm not sure
where it went i i'm having a hard time
understanding you oh thank you mr chair
honorable colleagues i did fill a pink
card out
i'm not sure where the pink card went
the pink cards you get the pink cards
out in the in the in the line yes i
understand that i already filled one out
no i'm sorry if i missed it i will
refill it out
okay thank you honorable colleagues my
name is representative megan murray i
represent the town of amherst new
hampshire i rise in support of hp 1674
and today i'm actually speaking because
i'm hearing across the political
spectrum and age demographics that women
are deeply concerned
about what is happening here in the
granite state with regard to
access to abortion care and the threats
that they
see
and are present
folks who whose ages are much older than
mine who are younger than myself are
concerned at the erosion of protection
for women seeking abortion
regardless of what happens to roe
women and families
seek protection in making choices about
what is best for them
we also seek that
through this
we also seek that exceptional health
care is maintained in the state of new
hampshire
and with that we ask that through this
piece of legislation it is codified and
protected that women have access and
families have access to abortion care
through this act
thank you
are there any questions for
representative
murray saying then thank you for your
testimony
and is there anyone else who hasn't
testified or wishes to testify
up in the back
thank you for the record i'm margaret
dry i'm from plainfield
my husband and i 40 years ago started
the first crisis pregnancy center in new
england
it's designed to give aid to women who
have crisis pregnancies find themselves
in a difficult situation
there were zero pregnancy centers in
1973 when roe vs wade
passed was decided and
there are thousands across the united
states now i believe that we owe it to
the women of new hampshire to provide
the things that they need to carry a
pregnancy to term whether they
chose to raise their child or give it up
for adoption they are strong enough to
do that if they are given the aid and i
believe that this does not give women
enough credit that they can they can
manage and get through a situation that
may seem difficult at the time there is
aid out there for the that is women
these days and we should make sure that
they get it
not that
and we have
changed so much since 1973 medically and
technology
technologically we know now what goes on
in the womb from conception all the way
to birth we know now when when babies
begin to feel pain we know now uh the
the the um just the development that was
not available in 1973
our laws should reflect that not go back
to a
primitive standard really from 50 years
ago i would
that you asked i ask that you vote this
in expedient to legislate
thank you thank you are there any
questions yes representative notter
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question um could you send an
email to us
saying what you just said maybe some
more details about what we know now in
2022 with the heartbeat and when the
babies feel pain and all that yes i'd be
happy and you'll probably hear it this
afternoon
thank you thank you other questions
and could you
also fill out one of those pink cards
and turn it in before you leave thank
you
any other persons who haven't had an
opportunity to testify who'd like to
testify today
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on house bill 1674
and the committee will be in recess
until one o'clock
hey
yeah she was
my fault
you
i know
is
the fetal heartbeat
yes
and then you have an additional
paragraph that also and then this
um
yes
the fourth
my
lowest
oh
is
well he does
he's not a very good one
so
when we were chatting
thank you
i just
here
give me any idea what time
is
uh
like uh
you guys
having hmm
so
okay
um
now
is
you
and that's what i read
okay
is
good afternoon everyone
we'll call the house judiciary committee
back to order
our
uh but before we uh begin our uh hearing
this morning uh this afternoon excuse me
i um
just wanted to note that i cut someone
off earlier
senator
perkins quoca
and i
and only allowed her three minutes this
morning and i didn't realize she was a
sponsor at the time
and i have since uh offered my her my
personal apology
for doing so and
apologize to the committee if i
embarrass you at all in doing that
the other
reminder i just want to make we sent
around a sign up sheet that comes around
the committee but that sign up sheet
does not
provide you with
mileage if you want to be reimbursed for
your mileage you have to sign the sheet
at the speaker's office or over at the
lob in order to be paid mileage for
being here today i just wanted to remind
everyone of that
and
with that we will move on to our
business for the afternoon which is
house bill 1673
fn an act relative to women's health
privacy and repealing the fetal health
protection act
the primary sponsor uh but and before we
begin i just indicate
for those who haven't been at our
earlier hearings that what we've been
doing is allowing the sponsors of bills
to have five minutes to introduce their
bill
and to speak to their bill
and then
we have been limiting testimony
for everyone to three minutes so
everybody will have an opportunity to be
heard here today
and so you should plan to do that when
you do speak
i would note that lots of people turn in
written testimony
and of course we'll read your written
testimony but you know what we really
want you to do is what we really want to
hear is what you have to say personally
and how this legislation may affect you
so in any event
i'm going to call upon the prime sponsor
of this bill representative smith
ask her to introduce the bill and
provide us with her testimony
thank you very much mr chair and it is
indeed an honor for me to stand here and
able to look at all of my colleagues on
the judiciary committee something that
i'm not able to do and i'm sitting over
there in the corner
some of you know that
over the 25 years since i've been in the
legislature i've divided my time between
the judiciary committee and the finance
committee
the very first committee i was on
was judiciary and in
lo and behold right there on the list of
bills was a bill
having to do with reproductive rights
nothing has changed in all these years
except a little bit here and a little
bit there the issue is an issue that has
appeared before
this committee
in fact
i say reproductive rights because to me
that's how i view
the situation many people
prefer to use the term
abortion
i think reproductive rights is more
relevant and relevant to this bill also
because it has to do with all kinds of
things it has to do with education
education about human how humans
procreate
education about how men and women can
behave responsibly education about
access to birth control
all of those are issues that help to
make sure that when a man and a woman
decide
that yes they
would like to have a child and be
responsible man and woman both parents
responsible for that child they can do
that in an informed way and over the
years
new hampshire has actually done very
well because we have an educated
citizenry and we have historically had
access to health education in schools
and therefore there were
fewer situations in new hampshire
where
people were caught unawares
abortion is not new
we have had abortion since men and women
procreated
abortion has existed all those years
it appears in the bible there are terms
where it's acceptable and not acceptable
none of what we do here in this
legislative body
is going to change the fact
that sometimes pregnancies occur
when um
perhaps in the best of all possible
worlds they shouldn't
and ideally we would have prevented that
but not necessarily in my very first
term
there was a young man who was
still in college who announced his
opposition to abortion because he knew
girls and he said girls
who had abortions because they couldn't
fit into their prom dresses
and i asked him if he would mind giving
me the names and the contact information
of those girls because i really wanted
to talk to them and he then said well no
he really didn't know them he had just
heard about it
and 25 years later i would say to you
that we sit here and we hear the same
kinds of things from people on all sides
about situations that may or may not be
true
we're not going to get rid of abortion
in anything that we do in this
legislative body one hopes what we do is
make sure that we limit abortions
uh as much as possible and that we
when it is
necessary that people have access to
safe abortions
so that brings me to my bill
i served it on finance for many years
and chair of finance and i can't say
with a straight face although i will try
that the finance committee never gets
involved in policy it only deals with
money
now i said that with a straight face but
of course it's not true
it's just as not true was the example i
gave a minute before
there was never any justification
for any language to go into house bill 2
having to do with abortion having to do
with ultrasound treatments having to do
with criminal penalties for doctors
having to do with everything uh with
the absence of
exceptions
for rape or incest or other calamitous
situations there was no reason at all
that that language should have ever been
in house bill 2 which is a budget bill
there was never a public dime a public
nickel or a public penny that went to
abortion
services
yes to prevention
but not to abortion they it should never
have occurred
a decision like that should have come to
a policy committee and it didn't we
today
can undo
the procedural and the substantive
damage
that was done by including those
sections
in house bill 2 that resulted in
on in medically on potentially mentally
unnecessary tests
for the woman who was pregnant
certainly
having to do with criminal penalties for
doctors
and eliminating
logical
reasons why
perhaps an abortion should be necessary
all i am asking you to do today
without regards to the three bills
yesterday and the two bills today that
we've heard on this subject
is make sure that the new hampshire
legislature behaves with honor and
principle and integrity regardless of
how you personally feel about the issue
of reproductive rights but recognizing
that there was no place for this
language in house bill 2 it is now in
our rsas and we can by adopting this
legislation
get rid of what was a
falsely
presented and illogical
violation of the rules of this body and
i ask you to support
this bill so that we can
continue to discuss the issue here in
judiciary in health and human services
in other committees where the subject is
relevant
but not have the finance committee come
in and do something that was not based
on the merit of the issue and that will
do nothing
nothing at all
to change
whether or not abortions take place in
this state except to say
that if they take place they might not
be able to be safe
and appropriate as they would be i hope
i've stayed within my five minutes
nobody's gave me to a close and i thank
you
very much
uh for the opportunity to speak to all
of my candidate and my colleagues who i
respect so much thank you
thank you representative smith are there
questions for representative smith
seeing none thank you thank you mr chair
i assume the vote's going to be
unanimous then thank you
a co-sponsor
representative alt schiller
his red is on okay
thank you
mr chairman thank you committee
my name is representative deborah
altschuler representing the town of
stratham
freedom independence and privacy
constitutionally protected rights
outlined in articles 1
2 and article 2b of the new hampshire
constitution
except when pregnant
when pregnant the state legislature has
a seat at your table
when you make decisions about your
medical care during pregnancy
legislators in new hampshire have
already decided that you are incapable
of making medical decisions for your own
health
this is an egregious infringement on the
autonomy of a pregnant person's rights
we heard from providers that there are
very limited number of obs who can
deliver late term fetal abnormality
abortion health care
and this bill criminalizes them for
doing their job
leaving this legislation in place makes
recruiting and training providers in our
state
that much more difficult
why would a doctor looking to practice
gynecology and obstetrics
want to practice in a state where the
state has made a hostile environment for
practicing reproductive medicine
where practicing safe and appropriate
abortion health care could result in a
class b felony
or possibly face fines of up to a
hundred thousand dollars
repealing this ban
is critical for providers whose patients
are going through potentially incredibly
complex situations
they risk facing criminal charges for
delivering critical care and patients
who are already in stressful situations
have to leave their home state to get
the care they need
the attacks on bodily autonomy are
relentless
and they are about
power
and control
who is a fully recognized and whole
person
able to make their own decisions about
their reproductive health care
the legislature has inserted itself into
the very personal and private medical
decisions of pregnant women
not just metaphorically but literally as
women are forced to endure ultrasounds
to even access abortion healthcare
it boggles the mind as to why the state
insists on a vaginal ultrasound so that
a woman can access the oral abortion
healthcare mifapristone and mesopristol
which can safely be used up to the first
70 days or 10 weeks of pregnancy
but first before you can access
that oral healthcare
the state insists that you endure an
ultrasound and
to add insult to injury you pay for it
too
who's in control of that situation
who is exercising power
it's not the pregnant woman
it should not matter if a pregnancy is
the result of failed birth control
sexual assault
incest or decision that best serves the
person whose body is actually pregnant
a pregnancy is not an invitation for the
state to jump in with medical advice
it's no one's business but the person
who is pregnant
it's their body
and no one here should have any claim on
what their very
personal reproductive health care
options are
unless of course
the underlying desire
is for power and control
i strongly urge the committee to repeal
the fetal protection act that more
accurately should be named the power and
control act over pregnant women
trust new hampshire women with their
pregnancy health care decisions
trust doctors to deliver critical care
to women without the threat of criminal
penalty
please vote ought to pass on house bill
1673 thank you
thank you any question representative
nodder
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
can you show me the section in the law
where it requires a transvaginal
ultrasound
we have heard testimony in other bills
and heard from
ob gyns that in order to meet the
state's requirement of providing a
gestational age someone who is in the
first trimester of their pregnancy
will not will possibly need a vaginal
ultrasound this we know to be true
follow-up thank you mr chairman but the
law that was passed was just to ban
abortion in the third trimester
in order to access abortion health care
a woman has to get an ultrasound they
cannot access abortion health care
okay
any other questions
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today
did i are there any other sponsors who
wish to testify that
perhaps haven't submitted a card
seeing none
we'll move on to the rest of the
testimony and again i indicated that we
would provide people with three minutes
of testimony up to three minutes
representative beth folsom
good afternoon this time
thank you chairman gordon and committee
for being willing to listen to my uh
statements today
uh i first want to clear up a few things
that i just heard
that a woman has to have an ultrasound
to
obtain abortion care
there is no ultrasound requirement
if they go in for an abortion
in the first six months
there is no state law that prevents them
from having an abortion in the six first
six months
they don't have to state a reason why
they want an abortion they can do it for
whatever reason they want the supreme
court has given you that right
all we have done is follow the
work of the supreme court where they
said
that at a certain point
in the development of that child
the state has the responsibility
to take that life in into consideration
when passing laws
so that's the first thing that i want to
do the other thing i want to talk to you
as a legislator
it is crazy when we get a law then the
next year we see saw and we see saw we
don't need to see saul we're pretty
smart people working in our committees
if there's a problem with the law we
don't throw it away
we fix it
and that's what we did in another
committee i'm on and also the other
chamber did
the number one
the number one idea that i got from
people which was so confused about was
the abortion requirement
so we crafted
an amendment
that clarified that no no
ultrasound is required until that 24th
week
okay so that i want to make sure we did
that we added to an amendment and we
fixed the bill
it has already passed the senate
and it's on its way
to passing the house
there is no reason for this bill to be
repealed there's no reason to start this
seesaw effect of going back and forth
every year
let's fix the number
one concern
that we heard
and allow that fix to go through
and put everything all the fears of this
abort of the
ultrasound to rest
thank you questions
for the representative representative
chase
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much for taking my question could you
tell me what you feel the number one
fixer is
you know what i'm going to do is there
is a lawyer who's going to speak that
has the language of the amendment and
can clearly walk it through with you and
how it fixes the different places in law
that were confusing
i was a social work major
i i just want to make everybody happy we
need a lawyer to to talk about rsas
representative simpson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative
i do just want to clarify that right now
what is the law
is that an ultrasound must happen for
any abortion care before 24 weeks
regardless of what amendment has passed
the senate is that is that right
i am i have never seen in new hampshire
law
that every single abortion has to have
an ultrasound first representative
simpson okay thank you i think you're a
sponsor of this bill
oh
so you should not be asking questions i
didn't realize that as a co-sponsor i
can't either not supposed to
i'm sorry mr chair i will keep my mouth
shut
thank
you and
yes represent mclean
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
is it
true
that the existing law as written
already clarifies
what this what the senate amendment has
but it just does it in the the penalty
phase
what the senate amendment does is it
takes that language and it also
duplicates it up front
but that the existing law as written
already says
this what you're saying that the if
you're in that 24-week window you have
to have
the ultrasound for enforcement reasons
but if you're in your six week seventh
week eighth week you do not have to have
the ultrasound and that is in the
current version of the bill is that
correct
um i i believe i understood where you
were going yes no ultrasound is required
in week 5 6 7 8
10 12 whatever going forward until you
hit 24. when they are reasonably when
they're not sure
and actually this is a is a tool that
that can protect the doctor
because if somebody says oh you did an
abortion too late he can say no
here is the ultrasound we did and it
shows that this child was only at a
gestational
place at 22 or 23 weeks
thank you
other questions
sing then thank you for your testimony
thank you
representative haken phillips
thank you mr chairman thank you members
of the committee representative
representative mary heck and phelps from
grafton county district 12. i rise in
support of this bill as a proud
representative of both the towns of
hanover and lime i'd just like to start
with a quick anecdote
about two weeks ago a physician at
dartmouth-hitchcock medical center
reached out to me and asked me if i had
heard about this new abortion law that
was going to go into effect soon
and that she asked me did you know that
our ob gyns
could go to jail if this law passes
i informed her
no no i'm so sorry you're mistaken that
law is in existence right now
our physicians can go to jail right now
for performing abortions
her response to me was just a complete
astonishment
and she asked me is there anything we
can do
the answer to that doctor's question is
yes
this committee can pass hb 1673.
so what does this bill do
it repeals those subsections of rsa 329
colon 43
250.
the proportion of the portion of this
chapter that regulates physicians and
surgeons in new hampshire specifically
the fetal life protection act
uh it was we've all talked about it it's
the what's known as the 24-week abortion
ban couple of points of the sub
subsections that i'd like to point out
is that this does establish criminal
penalties for providers that perform
abortions after 24 week period
it also weighs hefty fines of not less
than ten thousand dollars and not more
than a hundred thousand dollars plus
court costs for each violation
in addition it establishes a civil right
of action to claim monetary damages and
mandates
reviewing
a review of health care providers
licensing by the new hampshire board of
medicine when those physicians go before
the board of medicine they're going to
have a vaginal ultrasound record in the
patient's notes to ensure that they were
correct about that 24-week analysis
so it may not be the choice of the woman
or the schedule but in fact you will
find physicians will opt
for that procedure
under this law
if enacted what does this law mean
here's a few things it will restore new
hampshire's long history of honoring
granite stater's individual liberty by
removing the extreme abortion ban on the
books now
we know that this bill is deeply
unpopular with the new hampshire public
as 66 percent of granite staters
currently support abortion access
third there's bipartisan support for
repeal of this bill we know that gop
leadership including governor sununu
himself has gone on the record stating
that exceptions for rape and incest
for that mandated vaginal ultrasound and
decriminalization of our state's
physicians is critical
fourth we know the existing
law
has attracted undesirable medical
attention
and that would all fall away as well
if you could finish the exemplary work
of our state's ob gyns by demonstrating
that the state supports the
administration of life-saving health
care and it will recruit future
generations of the best and brightest
physicians to work here in our state
it's the right thing to do okay urge you
to pass otp
hp1673 thank you
thank you representative any questions
for representative haken phillips
seeing none thank you
rep representative
matt simon
thank you very much mr chair and members
of the committee
my name is matthew simon i'm a
representative from grafton district 14.
i'm here in opposition uh to this bill
i'd like to start off because i only
have three minutes if you do have
questions about how the ultrasound
requirement
works within this law i am educated on
that and i'm able to answer whatever
questions you might have on that um
but in the short amount of time that i
have i would just like to bring up not
so much what i have heard from from
proponents of this bill but what i have
not heard from them and what i never
seem to hear in these situations which
is whether or not
the victims of these procedures that
we're talking about are in fact human
beings or not
there's a specific reason why the
supreme court limited the constitutional
right to an abortion and therefore the
constitutional right to privacy
first in roe versus wade at the third
trimester mark but then seeing that as
insufficient during planned parenthood
versus casey they backed out to
viability where it has stood to this
point in time
the reason why they did that is because
they recognized what is painfully
obvious
we are human beings before we are born
there is a point at in time before we
come out of our mother where we are in
fact human beings
to take any other position is
scientifically indefensible
and so the reason why the state is able
to intercede at this particular point in
time is the same reason the state is
able to intercede at any time when one
human being
is trying to harm the life of another
the state is the one who has legal
standing to to intercede when
anybody who's out walking around is is
going to harm another human being
and so the supreme court looked out and
said well somebody has to have legal
standing to protect this child if the
mother isn't going to do it and if the
doctor is not going to do it then
somebody has to have legal standing and
who has the legal standing the state has
the legal standing
and so the state gets involved not
because we
i have a mother i have sisters i have
friends who are women i have no desire
to control them
what i do want
is to make sure that we are doing our
responsibility as the state to protect
every single living human being that is
under our care
at 24 weeks gestation and onward we are
fully developed
completely fully developed down to
fingerprints
if given the chance to be born
the majority of people at 24 weeks will
survive but remember this bill doesn't
just cover people at 24 weeks it covers
us all the way up till birth so this
could be a 39 week old child and if
anybody
who is a proponent of this bill would
like to clarify for me using scientific
language the difference between the
child a moment after it's born and a
child five minutes before it's born and
what the magical difference between
those two people is i'm more than happy
to hear that and have 15 seconds
so
unless yeah
and i'll finish with this
reproductive rights is a misnomer
reproduction has already taken place it
happens at conception what happens after
that isn't technically reproduction it's
nurture of some form or another
willingly or non-willingly that's
essentially what the mother is doing at
that particular okay representative
thank you
question representative otter
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
and thank you for your testimony today
um could you please expound on the
ultrasound requirement yes okay so the
ultrasound requirement um
i and i understand the confusion for it
and i testified uh to that point in
health and human services as well um
when you when you isolate the part of
the law that talks about the ultrasound
requirement there is no limiting factor
to that ultrasound requirement so when
you read it it seems like
an ultrasound is required at all times
and so i think that you could come to
that conclusion if you're not a lawyer
you're not in the judicial system in
good faith
what the bill does do later on in the
criminal penalty section is basically
say that there is no criminal penalty
unless
you know that the child is 24 weeks old
or there is a substantial risk of the
child being 24 weeks old
and you didn't do an ultrasound um so
for the point of the ultrasound is not
to pinpoint the age of the child that
was never the intent of the bill um and
i don't believe it's the actual effect
of the bill um so we don't care if the
child is six weeks old or seven weeks
old or 10 weeks old we simply care that
the child is not 24 weeks old or older
and so there's no need for a
transvaginal ultrasound which the
purpose of that is to really
magnify in on a child when it's in its
earlier point of development
it's used post-surgery a lot of times to
make sure that all scar tissue has been
removed from the woman things of that
nature
but it does no good in determining like
it's just not necessary a regular um
external ultrasound will demonstrate
whether or not that six week old child
is 24 weeks or not um it would be very
difficult for a trained physician to
to confuse the two okay representative
knotter did you have a follow-up yes
thank you mr chairman um would you mind
putting that in writing so i can review
it later i believe an esteemed friend of
mine has already done that for you and
we'll be we'll be giving it to you thank
you
thank you any other questions for
representative simon
singh thank you for your testimony today
and the last representative i have is
representative murray
good afternoon
honorable colleagues
i'm actually submitting this on behalf
of josie pinto who had to
attend class this afternoon so if i may
do that
i am reading this on behalf of josie
pinto the abortion ban and ultrasound
mandate that went into effect january
1st
has already had very harmful
consequences for the organization for
which i run as an abortion fund that
helps patients access critical care at
points in pregnancy and supports
patients who are in financial duress the
abortion ban means that patients will
have to travel further for care and
endure higher costs
this place is a major burden not just on
the patients but on our ability to meet
the needs of those
seeking care
to focus on the ultrasound mandate which
i believe to be cruel and medically
unnecessary i'd like to give a brief
overview of the current landscape of
abortion care
as of right now patients are able to
receive abortion care through a wide
variety of means
since the year 2000 patients have been
able to easily end pregnancy using a
combination
of medications five pills to induce
miscarriage
because of covid
the restricting patient's access to
in-person care the fda has approved this
medication for telemedicine prescription
and administration
this it means that patients can access
providers by providers via telehealth
medicine
this allows them to administer abortions
safely with their doctors
and with the ultimate privacy
abortion pills are 95 effective and have
lower complication rate
than tylenol
not only that but a provider shortage of
patients have to often have to wait
several weeks to find an
available appointment time for an
in-person provider
here in new hampshire that means rural
patients somehow sometimes have to drive
two to four hours to a clinic taking
time off work
to find child care pay for gas and other
expenses involved with accessing
inpatient care
these are massive barriers that we see
patients struggling with every single
day
in the interest of time i will just say
that i she strongly urges to support the
repealing of the fetal health protection
act today thank you for your time
thank you are there any questions oh i
won't be taking any questions okay thank
you
daniel
bushes
i i just would add
just experience with the with the
mask
and feel free to wear the mask and
we'll deal with it but
we hear your people a lot clearer
through the microphones if you're not
wearing a mask and because voices can be
muffled so sure but that will be your
people's choice can everyone hear me
okay
yes
how about is this better if i speak up
like that okay thank you chairman and
thank you judiciary committee for the
opportunity to speak with you today
my name is dr danielle l bushes i have
had the pleasure of practicing ob gyn in
the state of new hampshire for 18 years
when i saw the fetal protection act
included in the 2021 state budget i had
to get involved
with the efforts of so many we have
shared our concern regarding the
ultrasound requirement prior to
termination our concern regarding the
lack of exclusion for fatal fetal
diagnosis
and our concern regarding the
unprecedented criminal penalties for
providers who just want to do their job
i am here today as a voice for the
mothers and families who deserve to
navigate the complexities of her
pregnancy
guided by health care providers without
interference i ask for your compassion
when we help women and their families
through the anguish of learning about a
fatal fetal diagnosis at the 20-week
scheduled ultrasound these are desired
pregnancies
it is routine prenatal care to order an
ultrasound of the fetal anatomy around
20 weeks
a screening blood test in the first
trimester does not detect all fatal
fetal diagnoses
not all women choose to do this test and
not all women have insurance coverage
for it an early ultrasound can miss a
fatal fetal diagnosis
these women who present for the 20-week
anatomic ultrasound are greeting this
test with anticipation and excitement
if a significant fetal problem is seen
the patient has to be scheduled with a
specialty obstetrician which can take a
few weeks
if a genetic abnormality is suspected a
procedure called an amniocentesis is
offered that extracts fetal cells from
the amniotic fluid in the uterus
these definitive results can take up to
14 days to return
it is very possible that a woman and her
family is faced with the reality of a
fatal fetal diagnosis at or beyond 24
weeks
we then offer information compassion and
choice
many women and their families choose to
continue the pregnancy knowing that the
fetus will likely die in utero or die
shortly after birth
some will choose induction of labor with
her local obstetric provider in her
local hospital with access to her loved
ones
the goal for these women and families is
to have the opportunity to meet their
baby and continue the grieving process
some when there is access to it will
just choose a surgical termination of
pregnancy the key here is for women to
have a choice
these choices are met with pain and
sorrow
a woman should not be forced to continue
a pregnancy with a condition
these clinical circumstances are rare
but the 24-week abortion ban without
exemptions for fatal fetal diagnosis
does not take into account how every
pregnancy is different and every
circumstance is unique again i ask for
your compassion
24 weeks doctor i'm just going to ask
you to wrap up sure just one more
sentence thank you so much 24 weeks
or 24 weeks or beyond elective
terminations do not happen in our state
the 24 week abortion ban as it stands
without restrictions for fatal fetal
diagnosis will cause women
of our state physical and emotional harm
thank you for your time
are there any questions for dr al bushi
uh representative horrigan
thank you very much thank you much
doctor did he quite get your doctor
danielle what was your last name l
bushy's
okay
and um and of course the law takes a
very uh
understandably very broad rush view they
just have a one line description of
conception as you know the
fusion of the
sperm and the ovum and of course uh as
you know much better than
i do or anybody else in the room it's a
lot more complicated than that
so how
what percentage do you the approximate
estimate how many what percentage of
pregnancies um
you know ended either like abort
spontaneously or end in fatal
abnormalities or otherwise you know
don't go according to plan
in the first trimester we believe up to
20 percent of pregnancies end in
miscarriage
the fatal fetal diagnosis question uh
you know is too hard to give an answer
to these things are rare um and we take
them as they are presented to us um so
that
answer i
i would not comment on
thank you representative chase
thank you mr taran thank you very much
doctor for taking my question we heard
from the representative just a little
bit ago he seemed to be pretty
well versed in ultrasounds and being
able to determine
the age of a fetus can you tell me what
other way there is besides an ultrasound
how you would be able to tell the age of
a fetus
there there isn't or i mean specifically
early on in a first trimester that
transvaginal ultrasound has to be
performed with any accuracy for
establishing gestational age
although we use a fundal height
measurement in our routine prenatal care
we would never use a tape measure and a
fundal height
that may
supposed to be according to a
gestational age in weeks but never
without an ultrasound
claim to know the gestational age of a
fetus i thank you very much for your
answer other questions representative
notter
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking the question
i've had seven pregnancies and i have
never heard of a transvaginal
ultrasound is it new
a transvaginal you are correct in that
many women and many of our patients do
not
have a transvaginal ultrasound when
there's question if a woman presents
with bleeding and we don't know how far
along she is we'll do an ultrasound if a
woman comes to us not knowing how far
along she is we'll do an ultrasound
which typically is transvaginal early on
for women who have
uncomplicated pregnancies who are
presenting to us for routine prenatal
care
typically an ultrasound is done but if
that
pregnancy is 13 weeks along or at
certain gestational ages we can do a
trans abdominal ultrasound
so it is true that women who have
uncomplicated pregnancies
may not even ever have a first trimester
ultrasound which is my point in this
written testimony that in uncomplicated
pregnancies
some women their first ultrasound is
routine to have at around 20 weeks when
we can see the anatomy
for the very first time see
thorough anatomy
other questions
thank you for your testimony
oh representative langley
thank you mr chair and thank you doctor
for taking my question
doctor can you identify for me any other
area in medicine where there is the kind
of legislative oversight
that is applied to pregnancy
that's occurring in any other part of
medicine
um that i can you repeat the question
please can you identify any other area
of medicine that has the same type of
legislative scrutiny or oversight in
terms of what can actually happen
as do do abortions and the cure women's
health care yeah
that i can't speak to that answer to is
i'm not well versed in the history of
legislative issues for all medicine i've
certainly learned a lot about this issue
in women's health care recently but i'm
sorry that i can't speak of
how this
issue would apply to other fields of
medicine thank you
thank you is there anyone else who has a
question
see thank you again for your testimony
today
ian hewitt
i think you need to press the button on
your mic down there
there you go now
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee ian hewitt on behalf of
cornerstone in opposition to house bill
i have two points i'd like the committee
to consider one i've provided the
committee with electronic copies of and
i have brought physical copies of senate
bill 399 as passed by the senate and
house bill 1609 as passed by house hhs
either of these bills which cornerstone
supports would further clarify the very
limited scope of the ultrasound
requirement in the fetal life protection
act
if any member of this committee has
concerns that the ultrasound requirement
in our current law may be onerous i
think that's a mistake and i'd be happy
to address that in questioning but in
any case either of the bills i mentioned
would more than address those concerns
if this committee does not itl this bill
we would ask as the second best outcome
that the committee retained the bill
while it wait for the general court to
act on either of the bills i just
mentioned
secondly we think that some may ask this
committee to amend 1673 to instead of
outright repealing our current law
either entirely remove the ultrasound
requirement or add in an open-ended
health exception either of those changes
would make our current law unenforceable
and meaningless and we significantly
prefer the status quo ante to a purely
symbolic law having no law is better
than a symbolic law for reasons of
clarity and transparency and ultimately
we think better for life so to be clear
we think house bill 1673
seeks to authorize and facilitate crimes
against humanity
but if this committee is considering
either entirely removing the ultrasound
requirement or creating an open-ended
health exception we and our supporters
would prefer as the second worst outcome
that this committee otp
1673 in its current form and without
amendment thank you and i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you representative notter
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question uh mr hewitt um
before i ask my question uh we can't
retain the bills because this is the
second year but we can do an interim
study that's an option um my question is
what i meant to say representative
excuse me okay my question is um do
other states have a 24-week abortion ban
well abortion laws around the country
have been in a particular state of flux
for the last few years because we've
seen especially since 2019
a big push in democratic-led states to
repeal
modest late-term abortion bans and
authorize abortion up to birth it used
to be just a few years ago before 2019
when you looked at the spectrum of laws
around the country a middle of the road
moderate type of law was a 24-week ban
with felony penalties before 2019
massachusetts had a 24-week ban with
felony penalties it by the way had no
fetal anomalies exception it had no rape
exception because it was a 24-week or
six-month abortion ban
likewise with new york likewise with
nevada all these states had 24-week
felony bans
similar in many ways to ours before 2019
from 2019 to 2020 all of those states
effectively repealed those laws
authorizing abortion up to birth for any
reason
the most recent state to do that was
massachusetts with its so-called roe act
in december of 2020 which effectively
authorized abortion up to birth we in
new hampshire then went in the opposite
direction and went from allowing up
abortion up to birth to having a
moderate 24 week abortion ban
representative did you have a follow-up
yes thank you mr chairman does the act
contain an exception for fatal anomalies
in new hampshire
our law does not contain an exception
for fetal anomalies and it's a six-month
again abortion ban and i'd like to say a
few things on the issue of fetal
anomalies
one thing that i should say about fetal
anomalies is i have not heard anyone on
the other side in any of these hearings
dispute that the vast majority of
lethal fetal anomalies or fetal
anomalies incompatible with life are
detected significantly in advance of the
six-month mark
and so that leaves us with a handful of
exceptional cases on which we could make
law now the way to make law around those
exceptional cases would be to instead of
passing a 6 month or 24 week ban to pass
a viability ban which would by the way
be more inclusive and would protect more
unborn children than a 24-week ban
because you can be viable at 22 or even
21 weeks the reason that that wasn't
done in this case is you can go back
even to just 2018 in 2018 there was a
bill before this committee house bill
1680 that attempted to ban abortion at
viability doctors came before this
committee and said it would be cruel to
enact a subjective
standard that varies from case to case
and would sneak up on them and impose
penalties on them without giving them
any clear standard the minority report
of this committee objected
that viability is too subjective and
varies from case to case and that bill
failed to provide a clear standard so a
clear standard is what we've done here
and and just quickly the only other
thing i'll add on this topic for now is
that massachusetts again before december
of 2020 had a 24-week ban with no
exception for lethal or severe fetal
anomalies that did not deter physicians
from practicing in massachusetts which
is often ranked as having the best
medical care in the country and that was
in place for several years again just
until december of 2020.
and another follow-up representative
otter yes and this will be the last one
first could you
send your testimony in email form to us
to review later if you can and also
does the act require
the woman to carry
a dead baby
well as to your first question what i
have sent are copies of 399 and 1609 i
could also send to the committee
material to the effect that i'm speaking
on currently if that's what you would
like but no the the second claim seems
to have simply been invented out of
nowhere in the last month or so
in fact that scenario was explicitly
provided for in the drafting of the bill
the very definition of abortion
specifically states that removing a
child that has spontaneously died is not
even an abortion so it doesn't come
under the purview of this law
representative horrigan
well thank you very much mr chair thank
you very much attorney hewitt um
so you spoke of the
law that was uh enacted
during the budget trailer process a few
months ago
with
i don't recall much of a public hearing
processes
our law are you saying that simply in
the general sense that
we're in new hampshire you're resident
of new hampshire you practice law in new
hampshire or were you
personally uh or otherwise involved with
actually crafting the language that is
ended up in the budget trailer lawn is
now on the law books and we're now
talking about deleting from the law
books
i apologize representative horgan if i
did not say on behalf of cornerstone at
the beginning of my testimony i
certainly meant to i am speaking on
behalf of cornerstone as a lobbyist with
my orange name tag
and not in my personal capacity and
cornerstone did participate in the
drafting of the bill which was drafted
here in new hampshire and not with any
participation from any kind of outside
national organizations i'm not sure if i
can say the same for the millions of
dollars that have been spent on ads to
attempt to repeal this law i'm not sure
where that money's come from but our
activism was done here in this state
okay so understand so i guess
so you were one of the individuals at um
the senate
majority the senate finance committee at
least the majority there have consulted
with while they're crafting this
language
cornerstone i'm general counsel for
cornerstone cornerstone participated in
the drafting of this law the senate
finance committee i think you mean the
senate judiciary committee
as as to whether this bill went through
the full democratic process
it was passed in hb2 but its predecessor
house bill 1625 was virtually identical
it had a full hearing before
this committee uh at which i believe you
were present representative and that had
a full hearing before the senate
judiciary committee so to the best of my
recollection all the language that is
now in our current law went through the
entire normal democratic process and had
a full here okay thanks other questions
representative lorenzo
thank you mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question um
i would just like to know a little bit
more about your background
you said that you write policy for
cornerstone but do you have any
in addition do you have any medical
expertise on reproductive health
i have no medical degree i'm a lawyer
and familiar with the case law around
abortion
uh as familiar as any of the lawyers
that you're going to here testify on the
other side and i'd be happy to speak to
any legal questions around the law
governing abortion because abortion is a
recognized constitutional right under
our federal law
judges and lawyers from both sides must
weigh in on abortion it is a legal issue
and so i'm addressing the law not with
any medical expertise but in my capacity
as an attorney
thank you other questions
sing then thank you attorney hewlett
thank you
mr chair is prime sponsor of course i
will not participate in this
debate nor did i ask a question of our
witness but i would ask the chair if
he considers it appropriate
when gratuitous statements without
factual
substantiation
are made
by
someone who appears before us and i
believe that this witness did cross the
line on that and i'd like to draw your
attention to it thank you
thank you for your
[Music]
comment and your concern i have allowed
him to testify and
i appreciate that concern and
mr chair i would
i think we're all set your testimony has
been accepted and
we're done
thank you very much
former senator hood
thank you very much mr chair members of
the committee um it is an honor to be
here today
for the record my name is matthew hood
and i am the vice president of
government relations at
dartmouth-hitchcock
mr chair i i heard your um observation
about the mask i respect that
i have a four-year-old at home who's not
eligible for a vaccination so i'm super
uh cautious and i just wanted to preface
that if anyone has a problem hearing um
i'll have to happily try to articulate
not a problem
thank you very much um as i said i'm the
vice president for government relations
at dartmouth hitchcock dartmouth
hitchcock opposed the fetal health
protection act
last year for several reasons yes the
ultra mandatory ultrasound was one of
those reasons but it was not the sole
reason
we also opposed for the lack of
exception for rape incest and fetal
anomalies incompatible with life
we also opposed
for the imposition of criminal penalties
and potential civil liability on our
providers and the implications on
recruiting providers as a result
for these reasons we support this effort
i would however like to focus my
comments on the latter two concerns
specifically what the failure to include
an exception for fetal anomalies
incompatible with life means
to the woman who discovers she has a
non-viable fetus at or after 24 weeks
i think the doctor who testified before
me did a marvelous job of
explaining that situation
but these are the results for that
situation
that woman has to seek care out of state
she has to carry a non-viable fetus to
delivery
or she has to convince a provider to
break the law
in my previous experience i was told
never to question the intentions behind
or the motivations behind but i can't
imagine that was the intent of the
legislature when they passed this
with respect to the last point the
implication of criminal penalties on
provider recruitment i'm genuinely sorry
that my colleague the chair of our ob
gyn department dr alana cass is not here
because she would be much more eloquent
to speak to that issue as she is the
person who's responsible for recruiting
providers to dartmouth-hitchcock to
serve
a wide swath of the state of new
maternal health care needs
i do however have a statement that i'm
happy to submit
and if allowed read but one or two
sentences
from dr cass i write today as the voice
for women of new hampshire and their
obstetrics care providers
the fetal health protection act passed
last year imperils the lives and equal
access to excellent health care that the
women and families of new hampshire
deserve
as of january 1st 2022
many of these women will be turned away
from the care that they're that we are
fully capable of providing here in new
hampshire
they will be forced to travel great
distances away from the support of their
communities and families incur
additional expense 15 seconds thereby
compounding the inequity of care for our
most marginalized women
left unchanged i believe the fetal
health protection act will steadily
erode access to high quality health
healthcare for the women and families of
new hampshire
by deterring the brightest obstetrician
and neonatal providers
from practicing in our great state thank
you very much mr chair and members of
the committee
and is there
any questions for former senator hood
see none
thank you and nice to see you again
thank you very much
catherine paterno
you have to press that button again
there you go
i thought red meant off
good afternoon thank you for hearing my
testimony i am here today to ask you to
please vote against house bill 1673 fn
my name is catherine petternell i have
lived in wolfeboro with my husband a
practicing physician for 26 years we
have four daughters and i hold a
bachelor of science in nursing
it seems since birth my life has been
entwined with the issue of life my own
birth dealing with an unplanned
pregnancy and facing a serious medical
emergency while pregnant
when i was born in 1968
five years before roe v wade it was
against the wishes of my maternal
grandmother
she pressured my mother to get an
abortion
fortunately my mother refused and
instead released me for adoption
i truly believe that if i had been
conceived five years later my mother
would have found it more difficult to
justify bringing me to term
when i was 21 and single i faced my own
unplanned pregnancy i ignored it for as
long as i could
until one day i felt the baby move
fortunately i found a pregnancy center
that supported me and referred me to a
doctor who could help me deliver the
child and put her up for adoption there
are days that i regret not raising her
but she is living a full life
now 32 she is a social worker and
married with three children
any inconvenience or embarrassment over
that pregnancy seems so minor when i
look at all that she has brought to the
world
my husband and i have been through six
pregnancies together including four
successful births and one miscarriage
our sixth pregnancy put my life at
significant risk
i developed a condition called placenta
procreta the placenta was growing
unchecked
growing through the uterine wall and
threatening my internal organs
after much prayer i delivered my
premature baby at 23 weeks through an
emergency c-section
samuel was miraculously born alive
but only lived a short time
in that time my beautiful son was
cherished lovingly held by family and
close friends as he peacefully passed
away
i cannot imagine choosing to abort him
and never having the chance to see and
hold him
so as you deliberate on repealing the
fetal life protection act and stripping
away any safeguards for preborn children
think of individuals like me
and my daughter
who were given the opportunity to be
born and to live our lives
think of babies like samuel who despite
their short time with us were honored
and loved
please vote to reject house bill 1673 fn
thank you are there questions
cnn thank you for your testimony today
kayla montgomery
good afternoon members of the house
judiciary committee my name is kayla
montgomery i am the vice president of
public affairs for planned parenthood
new hampshire action fund and planned
parenthood of northern new england we
support this bill house bill 1673 which
is a full repeal
of the recently enacted 24-week abortion
ban and ultrasound mandate because we
think it is cruel
arbitrary and we believe patients should
decide personal medical care with their
health care providers not politicians
i just want to touch on two points today
although clearly there's a lot about
this bill to discuss
firstly this bill before you would
repeal the unnecessary ultrasound
provision which as of january 1st in
this state is required for all patients
who are seeking an abortion no matter
what stage of pregnancy
i know that the house hhs committee and
the senate have both passed identical
legislation to mitigate the harm of the
ultrasound provision but i i think we
can all agree the legislative process is
complicated and this bill would address
the ultrasound requirement
secondly
the lack of exceptions is cruel
throughout the last few months you have
heard from patients and providers
who have experience in these complex
pregnancies and who have shared their
experiences
particularly surrounding fatal fetal
anomalies
you've heard about these much-wanted
pregnancies where families have names
picked out nurseries painted
but who discover a fatal fetal anomaly a
situation incompatible with life
has occurred later in pregnancy an
example of this is anacephaly where a
fetus develops without parts of the
skull and the brain and there is no cure
or no standard treatment for anticephaly
now luckily these situations don't
happen very often
but they could happen to anyone
these granite staters are faced with
incredibly complex decisions to make
they must have these conversations with
their trusted providers and not be bound
by politicians arbitrary laws there is
no playbook when it comes to pregnancy
or pregnancy loss
families involved in these unique
situations they deserve our compassion
and our support
not judgment and not government
interference
we have some of the best doctors in the
world right here in new hampshire who
are trained and experienced to take care
of their patients in these cases yet the
state of new hampshire is now sending
people out of state if they can afford
it
everyone deserves care at their local
hospital with their local doctor
so planned parenthood believes this law
should be repealed completely
which can be done by supporting this
bill but
we of course are open to discussions on
how to mitigate the harm of this by
adding exceptions and removing the
ultrasound mandate
15 seconds all set thank you
thank you any questions from ms
montgomery
representative notter
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question how many late term
abortions were there performed in new
hampshire each year before the ban
thank you for the question
at planned parenthood we do not provide
abortion care after about
16 weeks in new hampshire so i don't
have that information for you but
i know there are representatives from
dartmouth-hitchcock who already spoke
and could probably answer that question
for you
other questions yes
the criminal penalty section of the law
says that
only
this law only punishes providers for a
violation if the provider is conscious
of a
substantial risk
that a fetus is 24 weeks old if the
provider skips an ultrasound when the
fetus is for example seven weeks old
what criminal penalties do you think he
would face under this law and why
so if i understand your question about
the ultrasound provision i think as
has been established the intent of the
ultrasound provision was
around the 24 weeks which is what the
representative from cornerstone and
representative
said earlier
but the implication that what is
happening is that because of the way the
law is written it requires it's required
for all
abortion care at any stage of pregnancy
and at planned parenthood of northern
england we certainly follow the law
even if that law does not reflect
best medical practices so even if there
is no criminal penalty on it we have
still course have to follow the law so
right now at planned parenthood and
uh and other providers of abortion care
we are making sure that every
every abortion has a ultrasound done
prior and you asked a question earlier
of someone about where in the law does
it say
that this has to be transvaginal it does
not say that in the law to be perfectly
clear but at planned parenthood for
first trimester abortions we it is an
internal ultrasound which was explained
already about some of the reasons as to
why it has to be transvaginal
do you have a follow-up representative
otter yes i'm just curious
would you do an abortion with without
ultrasound because um isn't there um the
risk of perforating a uterus without
without seeing what you're doing so
that's a great question and there are
providers who continue to provide
to perform ultrasounds
for every abortion
prior to every abortion but we're
finding and this is
consistent with best medical practices
updated
guidelines when it comes to medication
that sometimes people just don't need an
ultrasound prior a really good example
is if someone comes in early in
pregnancy
and they're looking for a medication
abortion which is a safe effective way
to terminate a pregnancy up to 11 weeks
if they know the date of their last
of their last menstruation they know
exactly how far along they are if they
don't have any risk factors
often an ultrasound just isn't necessary
they can come in they can talk to their
provider they can take their abortion
pills and they can go home and have
their abortion at home
so yes sometimes an ultrasound is
necessary but not every time
certainly okay any other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
the next person will be laurie safford
and then following lori would be frank
nack
so lori safford
good afternoon thank you chairman and
committee members
i'm lori safford from pelham
and my son ben and i are here to testify
against house bill 1673.
the fetal life protection act is a
moderate common sense law
that should stand as it is
like me most granite staters believe in
these protections for the preborn after
24 weeks
i'm also a widow and the mom of two
adult sons with a fatal illness called
duchenne muscular dystrophy
when they were young i was told by our
neurologist at children's hospital in
boston that they would not survive their
teens that i should take them home and
love them
well sam turned 24 last month
and ben will be 26 in may
although sam couldn't be here today i
speak for them both
when i say that although they have a
fatal genetic fetal anomaly
due to a genetic defect at birth
they are living productive
meaningful lives
not that it has been easy
they lost their father 10 years ago
but ben has a social work degree
and he works for a non-profit helping
other young adults with disabilities
sam is a musician
a songwriter and a motivational speaker
my friend rosalie stafford also wanted
me to share her story with you today
after an amniocentesis
when she was seven months pregnant she
was told that her baby would not survive
birth due to a diagnosis as
hydrocephalus
well crystal
kristen even though she had a fatal
fetal anomaly
is alive and well at age 21.
had rosalie listened to her doctor she
would have killed her beautiful daughter
doctors are often wrong
we are asking you to vote against house
bill 1673 today
and to give people like ben
sam and kristen
the right to life guaranteed in our u s
constitution
ben and i would be happy to take your
questions
are there any questions
seeing them thank you for coming today
thank you
as i said the next person will be frank
nack and that he would be followed by
jason hennessey
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today my name is frank knack i'm the
policy director with the aclu of new
hampshire
um so we support uh strongly support hb
1673 for the reasons that have been laid
out from our colleagues at planned
parenthood from the bill's sponsors
i just want to focus on two aspects of
why we think this bill is so important
so what hasn't been discussed right now
i want to dig in a little bit on the
civil and the criminal penalties in
existing law and so looking at the civil
penalties for example current law
deputizes people unconnected with an
abortion to sue abortion providers the
civil penalty section allows a spouse or
a parent
to sue the abortion provider if the
pregnant person had an abortion outside
of the the parameters of the 24-week ban
and again as we talked about yesterday
during the fatherhood bill
what this means in reality is that an
abusive spouse or in a parent who's been
completely estranged from their child
has standing to sue
for that for the pregnant person's
decision we think that that is deeply
problematic and something that needs to
immediately be remedied in new hampshire
law
second
again a lot of these bills have been you
know couched in this um uh the the
abortion bans have been couched in the
uh patient health
from the patient health perspective
again this legislation the existing
legislation on the books places both
medical providers and patients at risk
so as
as has been discussed there's very
limited exceptions to the 24-week ban
including simply medical emergencies and
the definition for that is outlined in
hb2
but because there is no clear universal
definition at the point at which a
pregnant person's life becomes
endangered
a physician may delay
uh treatment may delay an abortion
because of fear of both civil and
criminal penalties if they move forward
so we think again that is another reason
why this bill is important and needs to
go through thank you for the opportunity
to testify and i'd be happy to answer
any questions
any questions for mr nick
seeing them thank you for your testimony
thank you
jason hennessey and the next person
after that will be devin quinn
thank you mr chair honorable members of
the judiciary committee
my name is jason hennessey i'm here on
behalf of new hampshire right to life
new hampshire's largest pro-life
dedicated organization and our thousands
of members
i'm also a resident of empires new
hampshire and i have a phd in
computational sciences and statistics
new hampshire right to life opposes hp
1673 for several reasons
the first thing i would like to ask
though is that everybody listening
consider two fundamental questions
who is a person
and what rights do people deserve
some of the greatest depressions in
human history are because we've gotten
these questions wrong some of the
greatest human rights violations
if this bill was just about personal
medical decisions i wouldn't be here
testifying on this
but medical science says that there's a
second person
and the flpa
only protects babies that are at 24
weeks generally considered when a baby
can survive outside the womb
this bill would move new hampshire
backwards to have one of the most
hostile abuse in the country
against unborn children
allowing them to be killed for any
reason up to the hour before they're
born for any reason
the goodmacher institute a pro
pro-choice organization that advocates
for abortion says that 43 other states
have some restrictions on late-term
abortion
a poll as recently as 2019 showed that
about 80 percent of americans agreed
that late-term abortions should not be
allowed
this the flpa reflects a broad consensus
within new hampshire and across america
about who who deserves protections
and if the law is there to defend the
vulnerable from harm who is more
vulnerable than someone
who can't run
hit back or even scream for help
if we agree that an unborn child that 24
weeks is a person then that the child
deserves society's protections and we
need to take their interests into
account as well
this is not just about the rights of the
pregnant mother
there's another person there
when you hear people raising the issue
of criminal penalties keep please keep
this in mind
would laws against assault be effective
without a criminal penalty i don't think
anybody would ever suggest that
in terms
so i guess in terms of the safety i have
one thing i haven't heard mentioned here
is about the safety of late term
abortion
the mother's health is actually
significantly at a significantly higher
risk with late term abortion versus
giving birth naturally or through
c-section
and i'm happy to provide the references
on that if anybody's interested
um it is
being significantly riskier for fatal
anomalies it would actually make more
sense for the health of the mother to
deliver
than to actually 15 seconds to kill her
child
so in conclusion i ask that you not turn
back the clock by allowing a risky
procedure and with that i would love to
take any questions
thank you any questions from mr hennessy
representative notter
thank you mr chairman just quickly do
you have written testimony because i
missed part of what you were saying and
it was something about the number of
states
um i i'm happy to send some in
okay
other questions representative chase
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question i'm curious if you have any
idea who um
who's most at fault in late term
abortion or late term pregnancies for
abortions would it be the mother or the
doctors
thank you for your question
representative i believe that the law
criminalizes not the mother but the
provider
other
questions
xenon thank you mr hennessy for you
thank you mr chair thank you honorable
members
devin quinn
and this will show be followed by
samantha marcus
honorable chair and members of the
committee my name is devin quinn i'm the
director of policy for the new hampshire
women's foundation we support hb 1673
because the 24-week abortion ban and
ultrasound mandate impose inequitable
barriers to accessing abortion and
create a culture of shame and stigma for
those seeking reproductive care
a 24-week abortion ban places a
particularly inequitable burden on some
people who will be forced to seek
abortion in another state who may not
have means to do so
this would include low-income women
women living in rural areas survivors of
domestic violence and control who are
limited in their movement and travel and
those without access to transportation
a 24-week abortion ban in new hampshire
targets women who need local
compassionate reliable and affordable
care the most
the ultrasound mandate when applied to
people who would not medically need or
personally want an ultrasound sometimes
very early on in pregnancy contributes
to a culture of shaming women this
medically unnecessary requirement adds
an additional barrier and is
disempowering to women and individuals
seeking reproductive health care
we believe women and people who can
become pregnant should have access to
the full range of reproductive health
care including abortion free from shame
and stigma and we urge the committee to
recommend 1673 ought to pass i have
additional written testimony for you
thank you are there any questions
thank you for your testimony today
and samantha
and she'll be
followed by michelle foiesi
my name is samantha marku and i'm 17
years old
i'm from northfield and i oppose this
bill
knowing i could have been aborted based
off of a diagnosis that wasn't even
correct
makes it honestly surprising to me that
i'm even standing here today
especially considering the fact that so
many others are not as lucky
no medical test could say that i love
reading and writing
or show that i like doing puzzles
no one could tell my family and my
friends that i'm creative or that i like
agriculture
they could not say who i am as a person
everything i ever have done and ever
will do i got the opportunity to do
because i was not aborted
that is an opportunity that everyone
should have
but unfortunately not everyone does
the fetal life protection act should
remain in place
it cannot determine the fate of a child
before 24 weeks gestation
but it can protect those beyond six
months of pregnancy after a child is
able to feel pain
thank you
are there any questions from this mark
cue
sing then thank you
again the next person is michelle foisey
followed by sarah marco
thank you for listening to my testimony
i do want to let you know it's three
minutes and 10 seconds and i will do my
very best
to get through it as quickly as i can
i am a mom of seven children including a
daughter kayla ryan that i lost 16 years
ago after having a medical termination
in new hampshire at 22 weeks
when i became pregnant with kayla my
first child was two years old i could
not have been more excited for her to be
a big sister and our family to grow
we didn't have any testing through our
pregnancy other than our first routine
ultrasound when i was 21 weeks along
during the ultrasound i almost
immediately knew something was wrong
the tech turned continually went from
kayla's heart to her head back and forth
i finally asked is something wrong
our daughter
our doctor told us she couldn't explain
the findings but she needed to
immediately send us to a specialist for
further evaluation
two days later we went for our
appointment with dr kaufman at the
elliott hospital
upon performing a higher level
ultrasound dr kaufman explained that our
baby had only three chambers in her
heart minimal brain tissue and she had
severe hydrocephalus
my heart was crushed
he asked if we would like to do an
amniocentesis and i thought immediately
i don't want to lose my baby i can't
risk it i had been thinking for two days
no matter what was wrong we would go
through it and we would do whatever we
could for our child
i asked him
what our child's chances of survival was
and he replied unfortunately your baby
has no chance to survive outside of your
womb
he explained she would need an immediate
heart transplant and be because of her
brain they would not be able to give her
a new heart
this was not just a disability or a
situation of around-the-clock care for
our daughter she didn't have the
slightest chance of living outside of me
after our ultrasound we sat with dr
kaufman in his office he explained that
due to the measurements of kayla's head
we needed to make an immediate decision
she was measuring 22 weeks and the
current situation in new hampshire
allowed no time to decide
the available providers for a late term
abortion and their own regulations were
the time limiting factor he advised us
of our options including waiting for our
baby to die in utero going through a dna
or being induced to go through labor and
delivery as a mother i knew there was no
way i could continue to carry kayla
knowing she was going to die inside of
me and knowing that my little girl would
only grow closer to her soon-to-be
sister
going to work every day and having
people congratulating me asking details
about when my baby was due and what
gender we were expecting all the while
knowing we were just waiting for kayla
to die
we chose to have a medical termination
by labor and delivery we were scheduled
that friday for the cardiac injection
and saturday i would be induced
we met the physician that friday and she
performed a third ultrasound to confirm
kayla's fatal anomaly she emphasized
that she only performed terminations for
fatal anomalies
kayla was born still on december 10
2005. i went through labor with no
medication i wanted to feel the pain i
knew she would never have the chance to
feel
we held her for several hours had her
baptized
she was 12 inches long and weighed 14
ounces
her fingers and toes were perfect and
her little feet and hands were imprinted
and hang on my wall today it was the
hardest day of my life leaving her
behind when i left the hospital the next
day
a month afterwards we found out kayla
had a large deletion in her 15th
chromosome
if we had waited for those results to
determine our decision it would have
been beyond the 24 weeks
when you think of why this exception is
important to this bill i hope you think
of kayla
i hope you too believe that she has a
purpose in all of our lives i hope you
see that allowing a loving mother to
make a decision to let her child go from
a body that will not sustain her outside
of her mother's womb is the right thing
to do
i hope you see it as a decision made
from true love nothing more and nothing
less
thank you thank you for your testimony
are there any questions
sigmund thank you for coming today thank
you
sarah marku
and should be followed by maris tollen
thank you for hearing my testimony today
my name is sarah marcu i am from
northfield and i oppose this bill
when i was 24 weeks pregnant with my
daughter i was sent for genetic testing
due to abnormalities in an ultrasound
they determined that she had
microcephaly a hole in her heart a slew
of genetic disorders and that if she
managed to survive being born at all
that she would never walk or talk
we were told that the only humane thing
to do would be to abort her humane as if
she were an animal and i declined
immediately another physician rushed
into the room and said i cannot express
to you how dire this situation is you
need to take care of this as she put it
because after 25 weeks we would be
required to resuscitate her if she were
to be born
it would be too late to make a decision
and again i declined
it was never a choice for me because i'm
a firm believer in the sanctity of life
but i've often wondered about those who
waver those who don't have a moral
compass or those who are just too plain
scared or confused
these questions don't stem from any
judgment whatsoever but rather from a
heart of complete understanding as one
who's been there and who's walked that
road before because you see
i was also
i also know what it's like to be a
teenager and find out that there's a
baby on the way
had i given into the pressure because of
my age i would have robbed this world of
an amazing young man who is the first to
volunteer he's kind and compassionate
and who by the way will graduate from
unh this coming may with his third
college degree at the age of 21.
later if i'd given in to the pressure of
those in the medical field who were so
insistent that they were right and that
they could not under any circumstance be
wrong
this world would miss an incredible
young woman who is equally as gifted in
whom you heard from a few minutes ago
if you take the time to listen there is
a moral outcry from the people
from your constituents and it is being
drowned out by corporations with an
agenda and seemingly endless money to
throw at their cause they are losing
ground across the country
as legislators governors and judges
uphold the will of the people and they
have turned their sights on new
hampshire because they think that we're
a small state and that we're not paying
attention
25 states are further along
in this aspect than new hampshire
currently is
without even bringing into this
discussion the lack of constitutional
merit the massive human rights issue the
emotional trauma that post-abortive
family members live with are the
physical trauma and increased cancer
rates that post-abortive mothers face
it's time to take every possible step
toward halting abortion simply because
it's the right thing to do
i could stand here and bring study after
study as to the physical and emotional
effects that post-abortive mothers and
fathers live with but the strongest
testimony that i have is the willingness
to give my children life even in the
face of knowing that it would be
difficult and possibly even
not possible if they were to survive
with these abnormalities
at 24 weeks i was 15 seconds i was 20
told to abort my daughter
and because at 25 weeks doctors would
resuscitate her let that sink in for a
minute the repeal of the fetal life
protection act advocates for the murder
and dismembering of a child at a point
when the greater medical community
already admits that this child is
developed enough to live independently
from his mother okay ms marcou could you
just finish yes
it's time to stop encouraging the
slaughter of innocent people on the
altar of convenience and it's time to
stop allowing doctors to push their
agenda
the fetal life protection act should
stand thank you thank you other
questions from ms marco
representative chase
thank you thank you for taking my
question i heard you in your fast speak
say that a woman who's had an abortion
has a higher risk of cancer where where
do you have that information from so
that's actually a
matter of medical record and i believe
um
you were the one that had or that
new hampshire right for life has that
information somewhere do they not
on the safety procedures okay
i couldn't hear any new hampshire new
hampshire right for life has information
on the safety procedures the the safety
concerns with mothers having abortions
other questions
representative nader
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
have you heard of dr lan
fran lan frankie orland franchi
something like that she
she came to new hampshire once to
give us a workshop on
the abortion and
cancer connection okay
okay
any questions
seeing them thank you ms marco thank you
maris tolin
who will be followed by roy dennehy
thank you for hearing me speak today i
hope you can hear me okay
my name is
maris holland i'm a resident physician
in obstetrics and gynecology i'm here on
behalf of myself i'm a resident here of
new hampshire i'm completing my
specialty training here
your current legislation
banning abortion later in pregnancy and
mandating ultrasounds i believe sends a
message of mistrust
and derision to doctors who are already
i'm afraid in short supply and quite
burnt out
by threatening doctors with a felony for
providing the most up-to-date
compassionate and evidence-based medical
options to patients you invalidate our
training and our expertise
this is such an emotional topic
it's poignantly
illustrated by the different personal
stories that we've heard today from
those testifying
i'm so glad to have heard them and i
can't help reflecting the very fact that
individuals here that all of you are
hearing about their personal medical
stories from
having children with duchenne's muscular
dystrophy from having placenta procreda
each can have very different
opinions preferences and desires when
faced with these extremely challenging
diagnoses
it really to me emphasizes the need to
have an array of medically safe options
to tailor to individual situations
there is no one right answer to this
many women do not want to have abortions
and they do not need to
many women
do feel differently and having that safe
option is necessary
i do think i'd like to also just say
that
while i can only speak on behalf of
myself i do think that
bills of this nature that limit
doctors abilities to talk about
what is evidence-based and what is
what is
currently practiced in the medical field
it really
makes me not want to practice in the
state of new hampshire
i have a choice in where i practice when
i finish my subspecialty training and
these legislative
issues and efforts to restrict access to
life medical life-saving medical care
and risk restrict
the autonomy of patients taking the
choice out of patients and out of
doctors hands and to penalize providers
for
providing those reasonable and safe
medical options in these horrible
situations is frustrating i don't want
to see the repercussions
of these actions on the constituents of
new hampshire and i want to be able to
provide all medically appropriate
options to my patients without the fear
of legal ramifications i know i'm not
alone in this
please pass hb 1673 to repeal the
inflammatory bills
the medical community is really trying
to provide the best care possible and i
don't think it should be so hard
other questions for dr tolen
representative page
thank you dr tolen for taking my
question thank you mr chairman i'm
wondering if you could help me
understand something that i think will
probably result in
a translation of the legal words we have
here
to the medical practice so
i'm hearing that
there is an ultrasound
examination requirement that's that's
the act is titled that
but then there's this question of
a transvaginal ultrasound so i'm
wondering based on your medical practice
and your experience
is there a scenario
where our general requirement of the
ultrasound
effectively translates into a medical
requirement for a transvaginal
ultrasound or a more invasive ultrasound
is there some scenario like that where
it is a requirement effectively yes
thank you for your question
representative page um
it is confusing and i understand the
confusion about the ultrasound i believe
the way the law is written it requires
an obstetrical ultrasound from a medical
perspective an obstetrical ultrasound
just means an ultrasound to be able to
look at
an embryo or a fetus depending on what
gestational age that is
depending on how large that embryo or
fetus the term we use the terms
differently depending on how far
progressed it is basically um
you may need to use a different type of
ultrasound in order to obtain the
necessary information so usually in the
early part of pregnancy
the um
rationale but behind performing an
ultrasound is in order to confirm or
determine the gestational age of a
pregnancy how far along someone is and
if the pregnancy is large enough you can
perform that ultrasound and get good
measurements um using a probe on the
belly or an abdominal probe if the
pregnancy is
very very early it is
very challenging to see that pregnancy
because it's just not very big um you
know it's it's it's like the size of a
walnut at the very beginning you can't
see that with our ultrasound no matter
how good it is however
the way we see it is by using a
transvaginal ultrasound which
essentially takes the sound rays of the
ultrasound probe and puts them as close
to the uterus as possible and as close
to the uterus as possible requires an
internal probe
which can be very challenging for many
of my patients to undergo depending on
whether they've had a history of trauma
or depending on their physical anatomy
okay other questions representative
maclean
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
in the in the 24-week window um
which this
current law covers
what kind of ultrasound would you be
using to determine gestational age
well
you mean if if a patient if you already
know the um gestational age of the
patient i'm not sure
if there is doubt
that the gestational age is 24 weeks and
so you want to go in to make that
determination
which ultrasound type would you use
um in that
when you have doubt that it's 24 weeks
sure so so if you have a patient who say
based on their last menstrual period is
suspects that their pregnancy is
approximately 24 weeks you would use an
abdominal ultrasound you do not need to
use a transvaginal ultrasound at 24
weeks if
if you
do not know the age of the pregnancy and
and
it's very very early you may need to use
a transvaginal ultrasound
thank you
questions representative nader
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question and thank you for
your testimony today
could you and tell me how many late-term
abortions were performed in new
hampshire before the ban
i actually don't have those numbers so i
can't tell you exactly how many
abortions are are performed later in
pregnancy it's quite uncommon nationally
and from my just um
you know hearing uh it's not common and
there's not not that many places that do
it
however
you know
like i said
the there are situations where
fetal diagnoses that may not be apparent
at the routine 20 week ultrasound that's
previously been discussed there are many
conditions that
do not show up until later in particular
one just comes to mind is in the third
trimester there's a particularly um
devastating fetal diagnosis called less
encephalitis that cannot be seen until
the third trimester there's situations
where um
where there are tragic fetal diagnoses
that happen after 24 weeks so even
though it is exceedingly uncommon it is
still a a situation that occurs
not um
uh anyway yeah it's a situation that
occurs other questions
sigmund thank you again for your
testimony doctor
roy dennehy
followed by
i'm having a hard time reading it it's
james ostling osliner
does that sound familiar to anybody
go ahead mr dennehy
um
yes i'm a member of the
republican town committee in in windham
and i'm a resident of windham new
hampshire
and also life director for the knights
of columbus
i strongly oppose the passage of house
bill 1673
this letter is a response to numerous
letters from
the local democrat town committees and
the state democratic committee
to crying the recently passed fetal life
protection act
by our new hampshire legislature
in a subsequent passing into law by
governor sununu
why is why the outrage you may ask this
is this new law for the first time in
new hampshire's history
protects the life of an innocent
defenseless baby girl or boy
in their mother's womb from being
intentionally killed
via abortion procedure after 24 weeks
from the con from conception to its
natural birth date if you have any sense
of morality and you are instinctively
aware of what is right and wrong you may
say wow this is great
however according to the democratic
party leadership
in new hampshire and along with their
pro-abortion supporters such as planned
parenthood
emily's list on facebook
they are now targeting governor sununu
with over one million dollars worth of
ads demanding that fetal life protection
act be overturned
why
as the old saying goes follow the money
these new ads many of you may have
already seen on tv or social media are
expensive sleek and emotional
under the guise of focusing only on a
mother's product reproduction rights
a mother's health care
an inconvenience of having to carry
their baby
girl or boy to its natural birth date
so what happens when when an evil act of
abortion is performed
the simple fact is an innocent
defenseless baby is brutally killed in
the mother's womb
and yes they feel the pain
and he or she is sucked out and thrown
into the trash like common garbage
the dirty little secret is planned
parenthood is in new hampshire
and throughout the u.s
generates approximately five hundred
million dollars in revenues
in ninety percent of which are direct
result of intentionally killing pre-born
girls and boys in their local abortion
clinics
also planned parenthood is
is leading financial contributor
to the political campaigns of every
democratic candidate
running for state
for new hampshire state reps and state
senators
with this new law the governor sununu
signed planned parenthood and many of
the other abortion clinics
are now losing a great deal of money
our new hampshire our republican
new hampshire state representatives in
windham
and our two representatives senators
in windham and salem
15 seconds for i'd like heck to to
support the passage of this new historic
fetal life protection act they deserve
our thanks and support and the courage
under severe pressure in defending the
right to life of all pre-born children
thank you
give mr any questions for mr dennehy
representative dilorenzo
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
i was a little bit
concerned about your testimony
and
that you've
kind of phrased this battle this is a
battle between democrats and republicans
and you made the assertion
that democratic candidates are taking
money from planned parenthood
where do you get that information sir
that information is public information
and
i i did not say that every democrat is
receiving
contributions from
planned parenthood and other pro poor
abortion advocates but many are
okay
follow-up please is a follow-up
representative i just want to tell you
sarah that i have never taken a sentence
yes
first of all it's a question of
relevancy but
is that a question or a comment
representative it's a comment
okay then i don't think we need that
right now
representative chase do you have a
question
you you talk about planned parenthood as
if all they do is an abortion machine
are you aware that the
planned parenthood is mainly takes care
of women's health
and gives a lot of support with women
through many different aspects of their
life
this focus seems to just be on abortions
and planned parenthood is not the only
place that you could have an abortion
i'm just curious why
well
the answer is that
the majority of their income comes from
abortions without question it's a proven
fact
granted they perform other services but
the majority of their income on a
national scale
is through abortion services
that's the truth
okay other
questions
representative horrigan did you have a
question
oh probably i hope it's a question um
which is uh where would i
go to find the line items in their uh
in their uh financial reports and
actually just for full disclosure i've
never received any money from them i do
actually give them money every year so
i'm uh
is there a question well where's the
line item for the abortion services in
their financial reports so i can verify
your claim
i'm sorry i didn't i didn't understand
the question
okay you don't have to answer if you
don't wish to answer so
i'm not i'm not answering it so i don't
know okay thank you
any other
questions for mr dennehy
thank you for your testing sir
james osleiner
good afternoon my name is james oshima
i'm 15. i'm a student at oyster river
high school in durham new hampshire
you're going to have to kind of sort of
move closer to the microphone we're
having a real hard time hearing you is
this better yes
thank you
i support hb 1673 and i hope that you
will too
i am here with un with other young
people like me
i ask that you think of us when you vote
because we are the people whose bodies
you are regulating with this legislation
we are the ones who these laws will
affect in the future
we are the ones who will spend a large
portion of our lives
with your decisions in effect
we will either be grateful for the
protections you have given us and given
our bodies
or we will have to fight against the
oppression that you have put us under
so
look at us
look at us and think of us when you vote
we deserve control of our bodies we
deserve privacy and we deserve safety
and we deserve the respect and trust
that we can make our own decisions
we are smart we are responsible
and i assure you that we are perfectly
capable of making decisions about what
to do with our own bodies
thank you
thank you for your testimony other
questions
representative chase
thank you and thank you for taking my
question and coming here to testify
thank all of you for being here i just
have one question i'd like to ask you i
wonder do you think it's appropriate for
the legislature to tell pregnant people
what to do with their bodies
thank you for your question
no i do not think that is appropriate
for a legislator
to tell me what to do with my body um
i
think it was akin to when my mother
would when i would tell my mother i was
sick and she would ask me well how sick
how do you feel i don't have your body i
don't know what you're feeling
this legislator this committee does not
have my body
it does not have my life it cannot know
what i am feeling what is good for me
what i want to do with my life and what
decision is best for me
half of this committee does not even
have the capacity to carry a baby
they cannot
understand what it is like to make that
decision
therefore it should be left up to the
women and
people with uteruses
who
have that shot have that
child in them to make the decision for
them and what's best for their lives
thank you very much other questions
thank you for your testimony today thank
you
sharon mcginley
who would be followed by margaret dry
good afternoon committee members my name
is shannon mcginley i am
i live in bedford new hampshire i've
lived there for 24 years
some of you may know me in my capacity
as the executive director of cornerstone
action but i'm here today
as representing myself
i want to first before i
discuss my written testimony my my
prepared testimony to address the
question of the transvaginal ultrasounds
it's come up several times not only in
this hearing but in other hearings
related to the fetal life protection act
where it's said that a transvaginal
ultrasound may be necessary in order to
determine the gestational age of the
child we heard earlier from an ob gyn
who talked about the very fact that a
transvaginal ultrasound is likely only
necessary in the early stages of
pregnancy
if the woman is pregnant approximately
at 24 weeks where there is as the
legislation at the law reads substantial
risk that the child is 24 weeks it's
going to be fairly obvious at that point
that it is not necessary for a
transvaginal ultrasound to determine the
gestational age of the child
some of you recall last year during the
hearing on hb 1625 i shared the story of
my
matron of honor in my wedding my dear
friend and my college roommate who had a
lethal fetal diagnosis of her daughter
cecilia at 18 weeks at their ultrasound
and they chose to
carry the child to term despite the fact
that the child had a diagnosis that was
basically a severe form of dwarfism such
that the rib cage at the time that
cecilia would breathe her first breath
without
outside of the womb that she would
smother
and
they did in fact deliver at 40 weeks she
went into natural labor and
she was born alive but died a couple of
hours later not being able to breathe
and i can tell you that the life that
she had during that time in the womb and
the influence that she had on so many
others was incredibly powerful and the
fact that they were able to carry the
baby to term and to go into labor
naturally allowed the opportunity for
the family to hold the child to have the
baby baptized and it was truly a
beautiful life and a beautiful death and
none of it was easy that's for sure i
had the blessing of journeying through
her with that pregnancy
i want to share my personal story now
and that is that with my last pregnancy
in 2015
i was diagnosed at 18 weeks with a
developmental
issue with my son
and a couple of days later i had a level
2 ultrasound and at that time he was
diagnosed with a congenital fetal
anomaly although it wasn't
life-threatening it would require a
number of surgeries and that he would be
on medication for the rest of his life
we were given options of term the option
of terminating their pregnancy of having
an abortion another way to say it
my husband and i chose to pursue a
second opinion in boston at boston
children's hospital
and we went through a series of tests
over the course of the day 15 seconds
with multiple different physicians and
it was concluded that there was nothing
wrong with the child and that they
didn't understand the diagnosis and
although we didn't know for sure until
he was born he was born completely fine
and i often wonder what other women
would have chosen who wouldn't have been
able to have the ability and to go and
receive a second opinion and i can tell
you that our sons would be deprived of
the blessing of their little baby
brother foreign
thank you does anybody have any
questions
representative chase yes it's not really
a question but i i missed you said you
were from bedford are you a doctor or
just a woman here i'm your own i'm a
resident of bedford i'm the mother of
five okay thank you that's all yep
represent mclean did you have a question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so um we've heard
some concerns about the existing bill a
lot of discussion about the ultrasounds
which you kind of clarified
another area of concern was just with
the fatal fetal anomalies and they're
saying there is no exception in the law
for that it was discussed in earlier
testimony that massachusetts for a very
extended period up until 2019
also had a 24-week ban without any
exceptions for for fatal fetal anomalies
do you either personally or in your
capacity with cornerstone um have any
information or data
about you know how the fatal fetal
anomalies were addressed in
massachusetts during that time
and how they were able to navigate that
particular issue
well it's been said a number of times
throughout the hearings that having a
law like we do on the books now would
cause us to be challenged in being able
to recruit physicians um and we can say
with confidence that massachusetts never
reported having those issues of
recruitment especially considering the
fact that they are ranked in the top
three of medical providers in the entire
country
any other questions
thank you ms mcinley thank you
margaret dry
who will be followed by sandra
regazio
and we are getting to the end of our
cards here
thank you
mr chairman my name is margaret dry i'm
from plainfield new hampshire
today is day 41 for the fetal life
protection act though on the books less
than six weeks already it's been had a
number of chances to repeal it
a bill to clarify it hasn't even made
the house floor yet
rebuild repealing the statute would
allow abortion without restriction
throughout pregnancy in new hampshire
the
common reasons given for allowing
abortion after 24 weeks are that it is
rare and then it usually includes a
fatal
fetal anomaly or the risk of the mother
last month i sat through testimonies
from mothers
all around the state who though given
discouraging diagnoses like you've heard
today ended up giving birth to healthy
children
i sat behind the young woman who was
born at 24 weeks gestation and
admired her as i listened to her read
her testimony
we have almost 50 years of technological
and medical advances that weren't
available now back in 1973 when roe v
wade was decided
why are we trying to take our abortion
law back to 1973
when presented with hard cases we have a
choice before us we should choose to
treat two patients involved trying the
best to save both
knowing that sometimes we won't get the
outcome that we want
with all due respect for the very moving
testimony that i heard here of the
mother that delivered that baby
with hydroencephaly
repealing this law
doesn't open a door just for fetal
anomaly
it opens the door for everything no
reason
whatsoever there is a big difference
between working for good outcomes for
both the mother and the child and not
getting both
and deliberately causing a bad outcome
for one of them
i ask that you vote hb 1673 in expedient
to legislate and i have written
testimony
thank you any questions from miss dry
c none thank you for your testimony
thank you
sandra ragazzio
followed by kelly potenza
good afternoon thank you for hearing my
testimony
my name is sandra ragazzio i'm from
goffstown new hampshire
i oppose this bill
and i am here reading the testimony of
deborah bishop
of where new hampshire she was scheduled
to appear but had a medical emergency
with her mother so she's asked me to
read her testimony on her behalf if that
would be all right as long as you can do
it within three minutes
this is from debbie when i discovered i
was pregnant at 22 and unmarried i
immediately set a date for an abortion
at the recommendation of my doctor the
insurance at my job at the time would
cover all expenses
after a few days of wrestling with my
decision i decided to cancel the
appointment and moved instead in the
direction of adoption
my daughter was born in may of 82 and
she became the sheer joy of a couple who
were unable to conceive
three years later my husband and i
discovered we were pregnant with a baby
boy and we were overjoyed however after
some testing and an amniocentesis
it was determined that the possibility
of fetal anomalies is significant
impending
intrauterine fetal demise or severe
intrauterine growth retardation are also
possibilities another possibility is
congenital neurosis
although some infants can survive for
short time
it appears that congenital neurosis is
invariably fatal
this fetus is extremely high risk for
having some other type of fetal
abnormalities or impending fetal demise
if the pregnancy continues to viability
etc etc as you can imagine we're
devastated at this news but rejected the
recommendation of the doctor to end the
life of our baby boy in the womb and
rather chose life
adam wesley was born in june of 85 and
whisked away from us immediately upon
delivery to be inspected for any norman
abnormalities he was brought back to us
a short time later and told you have a
perfectly healthy baby boy
20 years and 10 months later during the
mother's day flood here in new hampshire
in 2006 his life came to a tragic end
when his car veered off the road and he
was killed instantly while driving home
from liberty liberty university to make
a surprise visit to me on mother's day
morning
little did i know 20 fewer years before
this
it would be the daughter i had given up
for adoption
who would be the bomb of my broken heart
needed while grieving the death of my
second child
she had come to find us just 20 months
before adam's death she calls me mom
she phones me at least once a day and as
if we were never separated i often think
of the loss i would have faced if i had
decided on abortion for either of these
people i would have missed out on 21
years of my son's life and now to have
both my daughters to help me bear the
burden of losing him has 50 seconds
he filled my empty arms when i chose
adoption and she has helped me to mend
my broken heart after his death
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
see none thank you you're welcome
kelly potenza
and then the last card i have will be
for state representative perez after
that
my name is kelly potenza i live in
rochester new hampshire
i strongly
oppose
this bill
i think we have to be very clear
about what this is this legislation that
passed
that has barely been in place
it is truly
a modest
modest means
it's um really stopping partial birth
abortions
and i'm not sure if everybody knows what
that is these are viable babies that can
live outside the womb
and so we're not talking about
women's you know a woman's choice and in
just her body and all of that there's a
living breathing viable baby in there as
well that needs to be considered
and so in regards with partial birth
abortion we obviously all know about the
partial birth abortion ban act that came
from the feds years ago
and i'd like to just
describe what it really is
it's basically when
performing abortion deliberately and
intentionally vaginally delivers a
living fetus
until the breach presentation any part
of the fetus drunk past the navels
outside the body the mother and then
kills the baby
um this basically
is
a
you know abortions puncture the base of
the baby's skull with its surgical
instruments such as a long surgical
scissors or a pointed hollow metal tube
called a trocar then inserts a catheter
into the wound and removes the baby's
brain with a powerful suction machine
this causes the skull to collapse
after which the abortionist completes
the delivery of the now dead baby
this is horrific
and we have people here that want to
remove that
24 weeks
it's already against federal law
what are we doing here and i'd like to
speak about what the gentleman from
wyndham said this is not a democrat or a
republican issue because we have many
people that are that have the r by their
name
that have stabbed us in the back when it
comes to that so that this has nothing
to do
with a
democrat or republican anymore we know
what's going on here
please um kill this bill
any questions from ms potenza
thank you
and representative perez
thank you mr chair the members of the
committee my name is maria perez i'm a
state representative for district 23 in
milford i'm here in support of this bill
enough is enough
women we need and deserve
the respect to our bodies
we have enough
as someone like myself
as a survivor
a sexual assault
we have enough trauma
but
by what happened to us
enough is enough
we need to stop telling women what to do
with their bodies
we're not doing anything
anything wrong
we try to survive
[Music]
trust me
it's not easy to stand here
and talk to you guys when some people
make fun of me
if people think
the victims of myself
we do what we do because we want it no
i have a daughter
she's doing me to have my first
grandchild
i don't wish it had her abortion but if
they
asked to choose between her life and the
baby
i wish my my daughter could be saved
to be honest
i think
women that we haven't we haven't done
enough damage
to women in our state that we need to
protect them we need to do what is right
for them know what it feels right for us
thank you so much
thank you any questions for
representative perez
saying then thank you for your testimony
today
that is all the cards i have is there
anyone who hasn't testified who would
like the opportunity to testify today
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on house bill
673 fn
and
the
unless there is other business we will
have a executive session on the 18th
at nine o'clock
that will be in our usual
committee room
and unless there's any other business
the committee will be in recess until
yes representative horrigan
yes we have reported many other bills in
an early executive session so
can we will we be voting on those the
16th and the 17th or some or somewhere
all of them be held over to a later
session day
okay the the bills that we have already
done the 41 bills we have already done
there was only one that is required to
be voted on
i do not know how many other bill they
all have been reported out of the
committee been given to the committee
staff people
i do not know how many will appear on
the calendar so
i can't tell you that today
thank you and i suppose we'll find out
what's in the calendar in a few hours
too so okay
okay we'll be in recess
thank you everybody
thank you
foreign
fox
oh
family
two
i don't want to
you